Boom, boom, boom, boom. Brian, Moses,
you are one of the saviors of comedy.
I want you to know this honestly truly,
really cause arose.
Battle Rose Battle is like one of the
last real like sanctuaries for horrible
comedy, like nasty, evil,
fucked up but hilarious comedy and the
way you do it where you make everybody
hug it out at the end and you, you
know, and you like set the ground rules,
no violence. This is just
joke riding. This is all,
this is just boards don't hurt us.
When I first came back to the comic
store was like how many years ago it was,
now it's like five years
ago or something like that.
Cause I was over and when I saw rose
bottle it was one of the things that made
me go, Whoa, this place is
different now. This place is chain.
It's like it's evolved. We brought like
come like as some like would have a, a,
a fight culture back to it.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
You know like where if you
have a problem, you know,
we're in a place where all we use is
words. Anyway. So Duke it out that way.
Yeah. Well not just that, it,
there's people that don't have problems
with each other and they just fucking
each other up on that stage.
There's like people who like
devastated friendships. Yeah.
They've ruined friendships, but
nobody's ever attacked each other.
So that's amazing. Cause I've been there
a couple of times, I stopped going.
It makes me feel bad. It does.
It's consensual. Everybody.
Everybody's in blue. I fucking,
I'm the commentator for the UFC
and roast battle makes me feel bad.
That's the combat sport. You don't like.
Just stop and think about how
crazy that is. That's nuts. Why,
how was that possible? Sometimes it's
so mean. Sometimes people say, shit,
that's so mean. You're like, yeah, I saw,
I saw there was a joke recently by a,
it was Jimmy Carr and Megan Gailey
and Jimmy was judging her and she was
battling a puppet. That's
how crazy this she'll get.
So this girl has got like a hacker on
comedy central. She's, she's brilliant.
And uh, Jimmy said something
snide to her and her response was,
I wouldn't fuck you if you
raped me. That was like, that's,
I can't believe I've never heard that
before. And his response to that was, oh,
you can say funny things.
Oh Wow. It was gorgeous.
I wouldn't fuck you if you raped me.
Let's break that down. Yeah. I would
have to be like this, like, hmm. I don't,
I don't know if we're going
along with that false premise.
I'm not going along with that
one. Why not? I Dunno. I mean,
you're not fucking someone if
they're rape, you know? No good.
It's not consensual. Right. You're not
giving it back. Does that make sense?
All right. Yeah, I get what she's saying.
It's just so hard though.
It was like, damn,
I wouldn't fuck you if you raped
me. God, that's just, that's hard.
And The lady said that to a man and oh,
it took him a couple of seconds and
be like, I'm going to let this happen.
There was some senators somewhere and
they were talking about rape and he
actually said that a woman can't,
unless she submits, he a
man can't actually rape her.
Wait, what? Unless yeah, yeah, yeah.
Less she gives it unless she tabs
out like I'm giving it to you.
It was something along those lines,
like it was almost like saying that she
kind of wants it. Wow. I remember that.
Yeah. There's, it was one of the most
ridiculous misspoke of course. Oh, he,
this book they made Mario
Lopez apologize for the babies.
Shouldn't be trans. And
he said, I'm still, my,
my comments were ignorant and insensitive
cause I wanna keep my job at e. Right.
Exactly how it is. He should have
added that she should've went.dot, dot.
Because I want to keep my, cause I want
to keep my job. That's really all it is.
Three-Year-Old trans babies. What
the fuck? Some a Blair white,
who's actually a trans woman,
had a hilarious quote. She goes,
a three year old trans
kids are like Vegan cats.
We know who's making the
lifestyle choices. Oh, message.
And she's trans. And she can
say that she's free. Free.
Like a bird. I mean, what age?
It ain't three should be in your 20s or
somebody should be in when you're like
an adult adults. A full grown adult.
Right. Three-Year-Olds. What's the matter?
Camera camera cut off. What?
The fucking government.
They don't want us talking
about trans babies.
Dead to camera tie. The court died.
Yeah. Oh, hi everybody. Um, yeah.
I mean we live in the weirdest time
in terms of like progressive ideology,
B dogma. Gender is a construct race as a
construct. Trying to bring it all down,
but race is not a construct because no
one's been successfully trans racial. Oh,
that's true. Never. Never been
pulled off. Even remotely.
Not even 90 Murphy on SNL. Yeah,
but you could go back to white like
Dave Chappelle. Just do it all the time.
Remember he used to do the
wall the crazy way. Yeah.
That was really good too. You could,
you could do black to
white and nobody cares.
You used to be able to white to
Asian. You can't even do that anymore.
[inaudible] transracial you could
probably go Asian to white people really
holding onto this race thing. Why
is that? Why do we hold on to it?
I don't know. I don't know. I don't
know. That makes, I don't look at you.
It was like, I don't even know.
I don't even know what you are.
You're just a tank. You know what I
mean? I'm, I'm mostly Italian, Irish,
1% Asian, 1.6% African.
See, I don't even have that.
I'm just like a N***a from
America. You know what I mean?
Like I'm just American black.
Well, it's, if you care,
if you cared that I might
look variety's interesting.
I liked that people look cool. Like
we were talking about Blake Griffin.
Like it's interesting that there's a guy
like him out there, big old giant dude,
six foot 10 albino look,
he's probably got all kinds of
shit inside of him that shit.
But I mean like when you meet a
guy like that, you're like, wow,
that's a different type of person.
Look how big he is. Like Shaq,
like when Shaq comes around UFC fighters,
there's a photo of shack and he
was training at American top team.
My friend Dean Thomas Dean is like,
uh, I guess deans like five, nine,
five 10 and he's standing next to
Shaq and Shaq is Stan next to junior.
Dosantos used to be the heavyweight
champion that looks like his child.
It looks like Shaq's child because he's
so small and Jay and Shaq still like,
what, seven foot? Like he hasn't
shrunk at all. He's fucking g,
he's a legitimate gigantic human
being. I mean, he's fucking huge.
I like the fact that there's people
that are, that are different. It's cool.
It's interesting. You know,
the real problem is racism.
The real problem is not that,
that there's variety and the variety
part's interesting. It's also like, man,
this new racism, you know, like
there's so much of the, uh,
the cancel culture and the, you know,
you can't say what you can't say.
And it's like, that's not scary
racism like it used to be. Right.
I think people are more scared about
the, uh, the silent racism than like,
you know, that over, you
know, aggressive racism.
You're like the lynching in the 50s
and forties. And you know, before,
while we all know that that stuff
happened less than a hundred years ago,
which is why it's scary when you see
photographs like those black and white
photographs of the
families standing around.
Why there's a black guy hanging
from a tree behind. I'm like that,
that is not that long ago. No. So that,
that shit is still in
the air down there. Yeah.
But now this new racism was
like, Oh, you can't, uh,
you can't talk about Trans Kids, you
know? Well that's not racism. But yeah,
it's, it's w that's just with
that is, is authoritarianism.
They're just trying to enforce a certain
way of thinking and behaving. And they,
they go hard on anybody who
deviates pour all Mario Lopez, poor,
nicest guy that's ever lived.
It doesn't have a fucking controversial
bone in his body. And he's like, well,
I don't think kids should be trans.
I mean, they're little babies.
And they're like,
what you wouldn't sensitive is cause
they can go after him for something like
that and he'll acquiesce, he'll give in.
That's almost like becking into
like that old segregated of a, like,
I guess like, you know, Jim Crow thing.
I remember like it will another
blanket told me Emmett till,
but remember when Emmett till gets
killed, right. It's because of, you know,
he's doing, uh, he's saying, hey,
you look on a prettier, he's like,
he's the only cat call to a lady, right?
And then this woman goes and tells
these group of dudes was like, Hey,
and they're just like, oh, we gotta
cancel Emmett till. You know what I mean?
So it's almost, it's almost the same
thing. I'm not saying it's, it's that,
you know, aggressive and violent, but
it's, it's the same thing of like,
you can't say anything. You can't
have a brain. Like if there's a,
there's, I want to say like a criminal
thought, now I'm having a thought,
right? There's thought crime. Yeah. I
mean, that's the Orwell Shit right there.
Just what people are deeply concerned
about as a Thoratec Korean reinforcement
of their own particular way
of thinking and behaving.
And it's because people have
the opportunity to complain now.
Like if you just didn't like the way
someone addressed women or someone,
you really didn't have a way
to broadcast it 20 years ago,
there's still like you just,
but now anybody can just get on Twitter
or Facebook and it can go viral.
And a bunch of other fucking pink haired
Weirdos will retweet you and next thing
you know, there's a goddamn mob after
Mario Lopez. Right? I mean that's,
that's what happened. It's
interesting though. I mean it's,
it's weird to watch it all take place,
especially from our business because
comedy relies on taboos and in a lot of
ways, like they're reinforcing us.
They're helping us because people come
to us for relief. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah.
Thank you. Yeah, keep, keep
the PC culture going. Honestly,
it's only making us more money.
It's making us more accessible.
Really appreciate that. Your store
has never been more [inaudible].
People were coming in like they're
looking to hear those things. Oh,
they're so happy when you go against the
grain. When you go hard in the paint,
they go crazy. Love it. They love it.
Bring it on OJ and bring him back. Oh,
Jay's fucking Twitter. Have you
been paid attention to the eyes?
Don't follow it, Joe. I just said, you
can't follow OJ on Twitter. That's crazy.
I follow him. Do you fuck? Yeah,
because it's great. A Doug,
Stan hope and I, back in the day
when we were hosting the mantra,
we had an idea for a having OJ
Simpson. At the end of every show,
OJ Simpson would be like a Andy Rooney
and he would like break down the problems
in America. That's what I think
about. Hey, Twitter world.
And so that's what he's doing.
He's literally doing what Doug and
I wanted him to do on the man show.
But he's doing it all on his own.
Like he was talking about the debates.
He goes, is it just me or
does Tulsi and Andrew Young,
are they the only ones that
are following the rules?
I'm just saying following
the [inaudible] getting,
give me some volume. Is it my hold up
goes to the beginning of second here.
Hey Twitter. Well that's my favorite part.
Is it my imagination that Yang and
Gabbert are the only two who know how to
follow the rules of this?
I'm just saying he just saying voice of
reason, but what you can't even vote.
He's a convicted felon though,
right? Uh, yeah. So yeah, like,
oh j what have you been involved?
You can't even vote because he wants
to know where everything's going.
I mean he talks about the NFL draft,
he talks that he's got a lot of sports,
talk on his Twitter, telling people they
should get paid more and you need to,
you know, draft this guy
and bring this guy in.
And so just the GM now. All right,
I'll let you know. This is a thing.
There's like you could,
you could have done some stuff like he
could have embezzled some money and went
to jail and got out or maybe
didn't file taxes. Like,
like if Wesley Snipes who went to jail
for tax evasion and he started talking
about politics or he wouldn't
care you like that? No,
but yet killed two people. Oh, Jay.
And allegedly he got off for that. Joe,
come on. Kill two people. I'm saying
he killed him. He killed two people.
I just think he's wrong.
What happened to Ron Goldman?
Nobody even talks about him.
No, nobody gives a fuck man.
They talk about the
wife. Yeah, all the time.
They never talk about the other guy.
He was like 25 and just to fucking wait
or man bringing someone sunglasses back
whose side deck. He was bringing the
deck. Right, right place. Wrong time.
Was He bringing the deck? Was
that, is that been proven?
They were sleeping together, right.
That's what it was. That's the Bambi.
That's also rumor. Allegedly. We don't
even know. We can't even ask them. Yeah,
I have no idea. I'm
trying to find a killers.
Ron Goldman world is there as like
a holiday. He does. He really does.
Ron Goldman day today. I'm
Brian Moses. Joe Rogan episode.
I knew his sister back in the day.
Really? Yeah. She used to come around the,
the set of news radio. I knew her from
back then and she was very nice. Tibbs,
devastating though.
It was like knowing someone whose
brother was murdered and you know you're
hanging out with her. It's
like always in the air.
You know it's always in the
air. Yeah. That's like a,
she had like a pin with
her brother's face on it.
I should bring you some
like black barbecues.
It's a lot of sisters there who
lot of, you know, brothers Gumbo.
But the difference is it's ultra,
ultra public versus pre-internet.
Right? Yeah. That was the biggest
thing to date. Oh my God, it was,
I was watching the verdict
with my girlfriend at the time.
We're sitting in front of the TV and
I'll never forget when they said not
guilty, my girlfriend put her
hand on her face. I'm like, oh no,
no, no, it's crazy. Believe
it. She couldn't believe it.
Cause I remember being like, I was like,
it was either elementary schoolers,
middle school and remember the Burdick
happening and it was like a split
verdict. My teacher who was white,
she was like devastated and
like all the black kids,
it was like me and another kid,
we were so happy. We're just like,
yes cause we didn't know any better.
You know what I mean? We're just like,
we're just happy because the black
guy got up because of what happened.
Rodney King, we're just
like, this is redemption.
That's how many people felt about it.
They felt like the Rodney king
thing was so fucked up that,
I mean the problem with the Rodney
King thing is you only see the end.
I'm Halley.
He led them on a crazy high speed chase
and there was fights and he was a big
fellow and he was on PCP.
So swinging for the fences until they
had to beat him down apparently according
to the cops. But then, you know, a piece
of meat like makes your bones stronger,
doesn't it? No, it makes you really
like impervious to pain though.
I had a friend who got his finger
bitten off when he was on PCP and never,
they didn't feel it h until you woke up.
I don't think he remembers
cause he was so fucked up.
But he was a boxer and he had
his, uh, his toe removed his,
uh, not as, not as pinky toe or
not his fat toe, the big toe,
but the one next to it and put it where
his index finger was on his right hand,
moved his toe to his finger and move
to the total finger and curved it
permanently so he could
throw right hooks. Oh,
there's not performance
enhancing? No. No. Not at all.
When you'd shake your hand, he
would give you like the little, the,
the little finger. Oh. Cause they
don't make it so it can bend again.
It was just bet like this forever.
So if he was punching you,
that was the only way. So when he opened
it, it would stay curled. Damn. Yeah.
He's a hard man. And he was on PCP, PCP
at the time. He was, we're hanging out.
I use my boxing coach.
He was a mad man. Yeah.
Legit bad man. Wouldn't that
be performance enhancing,
taking PCP like while being in a fight
because you can just get the shit beat
out of you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. For
sure. But you'd be too aggressive.
You would like if a guy was, uh, it's
not gonna make you a better fighter.
I mean,
you wouldn't want your opponent to be
on PCP because they would have no fear.
They would just come charge, not you.
They might be able to just fuck you up
just because of that if you panicked.
But if you are a seasoned fighter
and a guy had PC was on PCP,
he would just come charge and recklessly
just crack him as he's coming in and
keep moving and they said like the LAPD
eventually his body would wear out.
Your body can only take so
much until it becomes mush.
And there's a lot of people that believe
in themselves and they get flatlined
100% believe in themselves. You
gotta to fucking believe in it, bro.
If you believe you can achieve.
MMM, not really. You know,
if you believe in yourself or Francis
and God who punches you in the face,
you're going into the spirit world or
like what it costs beats you down like for
like eight minutes. Yeah. Yeah. With
club clubs. It like metal clue and club.
Yeah, there was that pre tasers.
Did they not have tasers back then?
So that was after the, uh, the Ciocca
cause you couldn't show guys out anymore.
So that's what they said.
They'd beat them down because they
couldn't choke them out. Really?
They couldn't choke him cause
right. They put a ban on chokehold.
Why'd they do that? Because
they were killing guys. Oh.
Cause they were saying guys were on PCP
when they weren't on PCP and they were
like literally killing dudes. Were
they killing them with their arms?
Were they using a nightclub, a stick?
One guy killed with a stick, I think.
Yeah, that was a stick. Then the
second case was a guy who, uh,
like [inaudible] naked choking them.
I know I do to kill the guy with the
choke in the ring. No, killed them in a,
in a jam. He was banging this guy's
wife. Oh, he really went for him. Yeah,
it was crazy.
He was banging the guy's wife and he
invited the guy to the school and then
choked him to death and killed him.
And then was driving the guy's car
around town. I think that's cold blood.
And then they arrested him. Yeah,
he was a interesting character.
He was a fake Brazilian
jujitsu black belt.
My friend Eddie Bravo called him out.
Wait a minute. Fake. Yeah, he's fake.
He's a fake black belt telling everybody
he was a black belt and Eddie rolled
with them. I remember him
coming back to me and he's like,
that guy's not a black belt. I go,
what are you sure? And he goes, dude,
he don't know anything. Like it
was crazy. It was like barely.
It was like a white belt and you
can get killed doing shit like that.
I thought maybe he was
doing it because he was,
maybe he was just being nice and
wasn't going hard. And he goes,
but then as time goes
on, I was really like,
this guy doesn't know
what the fuck he's doing.
And so then he calls him up and
he was like, Hey, are you off?
Are you a fucking black belt? Like tell
me. The guy's like, well, you know,
I'm a black belt in Japanese.
Jujitsu's go, stop, stop. Stop. Stop.
Are you a fucking black belt? And it
was like this big pause. He's like, Bro,
you're a fucking liar. You're a liar.
So Eddie separated himself from
the guy and then years later,
dude wound up murdering somebody. Oh yeah.
What'd you Jitsu? Yeah. Murder. The guy
with Jujitsu. You're single, the guy.
Well, you know, I could teach you how
to put a choke it in five seconds.
It wouldn't take long at all. Yeah,
I could teach you how to do it.
Just wrap your forum underneath someone's
neck. Clamp your hand, your bicep.
Put his arm behind the head.
Squeeze. You could kill somebody.
It's not a hard thing to learn,
but to actually apply it to someone
who knows what they're doing,
you'd have to get, you have to be
really good. Like you can't just,
no one's going to let you choke them.
But this guy didn't know anything.
So I think he snuck up behind this
guy who he killed and just choked him,
choked him to death. It's
not like the OJ murder.
I think he brought the guy to his school
under false premises. He's in jail now.
I shouldn't shout out to that guy.
Yeah. It was weird because I got a,
I got semi involved in it in that the
guy who wound up ratting him out to the
cops was one of Eddy students and I was
talking to the guy on the phone about it
and I was like, what's
going on with that guy?
And then the cops called me
afterwards and said, hey,
we were tapping that guy's phone. We
want to know what, you know? Whoa,
whoa. I'm on the fucking set of fear
factor. I'm in my trailer. Jesus. Yeah.
Okay. Putting my microphone on. I'm
like, Whoa, you're in a murder case.
I'm like, Hey, listen, I don't know
that guy. I go, this is what I know.
He's a fake black belt. I
told him the whole deal. Um,
and I had heard that he killed some money,
but I wasn't sure if it was true
because the guy is so full of shit.
This is how full of shit this guy was.
This guy had a friend drop him off in
the woods because he said he was going to
a Kuma take karate contest, like a
big karate competition. But it was,
it was no rules and it was secretive.
So he dropped him off in the woods.
Where was this guy from? I Dunno. I Dunno.
But he lived in California for awhile.
He dropped him off in the woods with a
Duffel bag. He gave him a duffle bag,
like he had a duffle bag with him rather.
And it's like a Duffel bag that's just
big enough to fit a trophy in it. Right?
Like about this big. So he, he
leaves, goes out into the woods.
The guy comes back the next day,
he's got a trophy, no duffle bag.
So he brought a fucking trophy with him
and then he came out of the woods like,
yeah, I won a fucked everybody
up. And like, so this guy would,
he thought this guy would tell everybody
that he be beat everybody in this
karate tournament. You guys a
hell of an actor? He's really,
I mean he really commits. He was,
he was one of those guys that snuck
through my crazy radar cause he's a friend
of a friend. So I was, I assumed,
you know, I was fucking 30 years old.
I didn't know any better.
I was dumb. And I was like,
I assumed 30 30 once you fully cooked
by them. Nah, you think you are.
You don't think you are. You haven't
met enough murderers yet. Shit.
You have to meet enough really legitimate,
crazy people that have them
in the database. We were
like, Oh, you're fucking,
you're a sociopath. Oh
well what's worth worse?
A psycho or sociopath, sociopath. As
someone who doesn't care about someone,
a psychopath. I think as someone
who violently attacks people,
but in many ways they're interchangeable,
like go. So let's Google that.
What is the difference between
a sociopath and a psychopath?
Because I think a sociopath
can have no violent tendencies,
but I think the idea is
that they have no compassion
for other people. Right?
Like I have a friend and she
thinks her sisters associate belts.
Everybody thinks that everybody's
a fucking sociopath these days.
That's like a hot, that's
the hot word these days.
Like calling somebody a racist or
on someone and Nazi. Exactly. Yeah.
The quick thing I pulled
out and we'll put it up.
So will you explain exactly what it said,
but there's just like a venn diagram.
It's, that's a better
explanation. By the way,
every woman who's you know who's
going to hear this, he'll be like,
he is a sociopath. So there's
something in the middle. There's like,
you could be both.
So genetically predisposed psych
about genetically predisposed.
My parents would have to be psychopaths.
What's happening with the screen there,
buddy?
I switched. I would have done on purpose.
You should connect again. Maybe not
to be, it's dead. There it goes.
Oh, even better. Okay. Lacks
empathy. A psych is psychopath.
Genetically predisposed
lacks empathy and guilt.
Convincing behavior like how
they spell behavior. That's, Oh,
going I even Kenai tonight. But look
how, so let's spell behavior. Oh yeah.
With the io Io, you are higher
job success. Why? That's okay.
Antisocial personality disorders can
form social relationships and treatable.
That's the one in the middle. Okay. So
the no path, environmentally influenced,
feel empathy and guilt, erratic
behavior struggles to find a keep chops.
Wait a minute. I thought
sociopath didn't feel empathy.
I think that was just a British,
definitely psychopath doesn't change it
like it's the same one that was still
doing path. Does care, sociopath would
feel no guilt about hurting a stranger.
So how is that saying? Same
thing, but it's not the same.
The same thing it says, it
feels, they feel empathy.
When you look at that chart it
says sociopath feel empathy,
whatever. It's close. We kind
of get it and kill it. Sure.
But I feel like a lot of a, you
know, stand up comics as, as,
as much as they're narcissistic, they
might, they might also be sociopath.
Think a lot of people that get to a
point in their career where there's,
they're trying so hard to be successful
that it becomes all about them.
Right?
Like it's becomes such an obsession and
the narcissism is so strong that all
they really care about is their own
good and their own, their own success.
Right. And they'll fuck people over.
That's, that's a fact. I mean, yeah,
I've seen it. Yeah. It's kind of
sociopathic. Yeah. Have you lived it?
Live it a little bit. A little bit.
And we'll talk. We'll talk about,
or you wanna keep it honest.
We should keep it on the hush.
We can't break it on this one.
We'll come back to that one.
We'll do that when the cameras stopped
rolling. Those experiences, you know,
when you find it,
you find it when you start getting a
little bit of success and it's like even
much, right? You can be anything.
You get a development deal and all
of a sudden people are like, oh,
there's people that equate good things
happening to other people as bad things
happening to them. And
that's the narcism. That's
that. Yeah. That's dream Egomania.
Right. Extreme extreme narcissism.
And obviously you have to be, this
has to be something wrong with you.
Most of the time, not,
not 100% of the time,
but most of the time to want to
be a comedian. Right? Absolutely.
And something's gotta be wrong.
Cause this is like your ego gets
kicked in the Dick every day.
Especially in this town. So
just taking that every day,
you have to have something a
little wrong with you. Yeah, yeah.
No better way to see it than the
goddamn open mic nights, bro.
Oh, the store. I don't,
I can't go anymore.
I used to be able to go and just
watch, but now it's so fucking crazy.
It's just, I can't, especially the comedy
store because now there's a crowd now.
I mean back when, I mean, I
remember when I was like coming up,
there was no crowd. It was just,
it was just your peers open.
Mike nights are pack pack. Yeah. Like
with a real audience. Yeah. Like that's,
you guys would guys are stealing.
There's people that are fans of comedy
now that want to see the process.
Really? Yeah. Is that what that
is? Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a wonder that change
podcast. Oh, that makes sense.
We started talking about it on
podcasts and next thing you know,
I think over the last
like six, seven years,
you start to see people that are
like, I want to know what it's like.
What does it cause? They love going
to see like headliners. Like if you,
if you love going to see
the fully finished product,
you want to see what it's like to see.
It's almost like going to
watch an amateur's fight.
Like I'll keep an eye on him. Maybe one
day he'll be the champ. I hear that.
But then it's also, I mean there's
that, but I feel like spiting yeah,
you can kind of see somebody
style here and there.
But with comedy you see everybody
started going to see a young guy who's
probably doing like a Dave Chappelle
type of thing and the guys who are like
doing Jim Gaffigan captain thing,
you know Joe Rogan kind of thing,
you know Mitch Hedberg
kind of thing. Yeah.
So that's just what opened Mike and we're
going to see a bunch of copycats until
they figured out. You can't just do that.
But what's cool about it is you go from
that and then you can go into the other
room. Like you can go into the main room
and there'll be a real show going on.
Kill Tony. Yeah. So you could
see both on the same day,
like you really can, you can
go see a real comic. Yeah.
You can see open mic night and then
at the end of the open mic night,
like Chappelle shows up at pop up
all the time. Right dice clay. Yeah,
all the time.
So you literally watched these amateurs
and then boom of like a world renowned
professional shows up. You're like,
oh, that's the finished product.
We get it though. Yeah. But
yeah, they're never going to be,
I mean that's crazy. That's the
guy. But somebody used to be,
I mean Chappelle was an open miker we
all were open makers. When did you start?
Like oh, how old were you? 88 I was
21. 21. Okay. Yeah, he was like, what?
14 when he started like he was a
baby. Yeah. Wouldn't even get in. Um,
I think they'd let him in. I
didn't know you could get in.
I thought you had to be 21,
because the same bar and it turns out
there's like a law where you can be,
I think in Massachusetts you could be
18 with like a note to perform at a
nightclub. Dave said to make sure
that they didn't serve you alcohol.
When I met Dave,
I think Dave is like four or five
years younger than me and I was 23 or
something like that. And he was
a baby at 17 probably. Yeah.
Yeah. I met him at the catch rising star
catch rising star in Boston. All right.
Not In Boston. In New York. Yeah. Yeah.
I was already passed all
the clubs at that point. Um,
he must have been, he must have been,
he was on stage and they were
already talking about, I'm like,
look at this young kid, like he's so
talented. I remember the Silverman Sarah,
she was telling me, she was like, I
remember when a Chappelle got, no,
Brooks is uh, one of
the last films, the uh,
men in tights and it was like the big
talk in New York. And she's like, hey,
that 19 year old kid just got a
a millbrook's, you know, do, wow.
The world was a different
place back then. Yeah,
it was Isaac Hayes was alive.
Yeah, that's true. Yeah.
So it was different times. There
was a, you guys were scared of aids.
This was the 90s right.
So, yeah, so aids was big.
You couldn't really fuck anybody.
The first time I got an aids test
I was so nervous. Really? Oh yeah.
It just was a slideshow. Every
bad decision I'd ever made.
Every time I never wore condoms,
just going through my hand,
cause everybody was convinced there was a,
it was funny because at the same time
Kennison had a bit where he goes like,
they say Sam, they say aids
is a communicable disease.
Straight people can get
it too. He goes, no,
fuck you. It's not our
dance. And people were so,
you know, people were so mad. Well, I'm
glad now, but I was just, you know, we,
when it happened, I remember in my car,
I was living in Boston in my car driving
and I was listening to the radio and
Magic Johnson had a press conference to
announce that he had HIV and it was like
a scene in a Zombie movie where the
first person got bit and I was like,
oh my God, it's happening. Holy Shit.
Oh my God. Magic Johnson
with all his money.
That guy's got HIV. Yeah. Oh my
God, we're fucked. We're fucked.
I remember thinking that. And then, um,
it was probably like a year or two
later I got, I got an aids test
after magic. Got It. Two years later
I didn't have health insurance.
Forget there was like they cost
money back then. Oh yeah, yeah.
Pigs another just free. Yeah.
Well now they want people to not get aids
or people just get aid sometimes just
to get the free healthcare. Really?
Yeah. There's, I mean, I've wanted this,
this is a rumor on the Strip
her in the gay community,
cause I live in the gay
community and not that I am,
but I'm saying I live there because it's
clean and [inaudible] wrong with gay
people. Right, exactly. There's
nothing wrong, right. Anyway,
a gay neighborhood cause it's safe. It's
safe. Oh my God, it's, I said, yeah,
I just worry about, you know, anyway,
uh, but Dr Keys, when you're naked,
you don't go outside naked anymore jail.
Uh, but yeah, they uh, they say like,
yeah, some guys will just get it
just like the free healthcare.
This is before Obamacare, there
was a thing called bug chasers.
Do you know what that is? It was gay
dudes that for whatever reason, look,
a lot of people are self-loathing,
right? There's people cut themselves.
People that tattoo their face, they
hate themselves for whatever reason,
and they punish themselves
while they was host.
Malone hates himself tattoo on his
face. There's got to be something wrong.
Mike Tyson, like Tyson, I
think he had some issues. Yeah.
He's my favorite by the way.
Love Him. He is my spirit animal.
I fucking love Mike Tyson. I got
Tyson weed over there. If you want to.
Do you smoke weed? Yeah, I smoke.
How often? Every day. Every day.
You want suboxone right now?
Tyson. We'd hope mom. Sorry.
Breaking out the good stuff. That's
gonna knock me out. Let's do it
like Tyson. Holler at me. Please.
Find some Tyson ranch original staff,
I think in California
city do I grew up out.
That's what the other earthquakes
are. Oh Shit. Oh yeah.
I think they're launching it soon.
The ranch, the ranch. Oh Shit.
He brought us a golden box. Look at
that box back there. It's amazing.
Who made that? It wasn't
man. Whoever knows. Mike.
What was he on? Put episodes up
to say a few months back. Oh Shit.
The bamboo. Can't believe
he never smoked weed before.
Did we ever never ever drink
together? We haven't smoked together.
That's outrageous.
Outrageous, joyous occasion.
But anyway, there was bug chasers.
Bug Chasers were dudes that for whatever
reason, for whatever reason, they,
um, they wanted to catch
HIV. They want it to, what?
I wanted to call them bug chasers.
They would literally go
out and try to get it. Why?
I mean they hated themselves. They
wanted a dog. This is a real thing. Yeah.
This is the, okay this is like,
like black kids would be like the
death by cop thing. Yes, yes. Yeah.
And not just black kids.
You see that video recently the guy was
running towards the cop with a knife and
he's fucking screaming
and yelling and he's like,
don't make me shoot you
tell him. Shoot you.
He just wanted to know to
start to unloaded on the
guy. Suicide by cop is super,
super common. I did not know that. Yeah,
I thought it was just a good thing.
Now it's a, it's a real common
thing but a bug chasers were,
I mean maybe it's still a thing but now
aids is dude aids is aids is the apple
of diseases. It's the Oprah diseases.
Honestly it's like when
Magic Johnson got it,
aids was like our stock's about
to go up like fucking Disney.
I mean,
cause you think about cracking aids kind
of came into the same time and crack
was killing it and all of a sudden
now aids is like you get aids.
It's like you've, it's not that.
That's a hit track. Yeah. Yeah.
Like look at fucking Charlie Sheen.
He looks great. Looks Great Dude.
Jeff at the comedy store. Yeah. Check
the comments. Just had it forever. Yeah,
he had it like back when it wasn't
cool before. It was cool. Still got it.
It looks great. It looks great. It's
still got it, but it's HIV aids,
full blown AIDS, but nobody gets it.
Nobody gets full blown. Some
people do. Really? Yeah.
It's just going to live a
full blown, I don't know.
I don't know why they get it. Maybe some
people don't react to the medication.
Maybe some people don't get
treated full-blown. Well,
we can live a full blown,
I don't know. Think you'll live
very long and then once you get,
you can live with HIV. Yes.
Well now they can get it to the
point where you're HIV. By the way,
if you're a doctor and you listen
to this, we're sorry. I know we're
here. Like you guys don't know Jack Shit.
No idea what you're talking about. Um,
but if you, uh, here it goes,
death usually occurs within six
months to three years from the time of
developing full blown AIDS,
people living with aids.
Is there any other disease
that has full blown?
It's only aids write a rap
name. You get full blown flu,
full blown aids and that's the scientific
term in the West that's so blown out.
That's sound like that.
So Slang overloads and put that
back up so I can read it again.
I was looking for other things
with full blown in it. No,
there's nothing else
with full bone. It uh,
people living with aids go
through periods of being sick,
alternating with periods
of reasonable health.
It's usually one of the many opportunistic
infections that eventually caused
death. So yeah, your,
your immune system smashed and
that causes death full blown.
Yeah, full blown. But HIV should,
he's like 38 now. Yeah. Shit.
HIV has been around for a minute
and happy birthday now. It's, um,
where the point where you,
you can be undetectable,
like magic Johnson's
apparently undetectable, right?
Like even through aids tests,
like when you test him for HIV
show's HIV negative or really, yeah,
but they say it's still dormant
in the system somehow or another.
It's very confused. It's like,
like herpes almost not for him.
Like it flares up.
I think if you ever heard [inaudible]
even if you don't have an outbreak,
if they test you, it'll show that you
have herpes. Oh, but with HIV, yeah, with,
with the way they have the medication,
the way the body responds
to the medication now it
at least in some cases like
Magic Johnson is apparently
he shows up HIV negative.
But the weird thing is like, well
isn't he cured then? Is that cured?
They've only two people
and he's not one of them.
So when they have started curing
people, which I was like, okay,
well how do they differentiate?
Like what's the difference between curing
someone and what's going on with Magic
Johnson with when he's HIV negative,
if you're anything else negative,
they figured they cured you. Yeah. They
haven't actually. Yeah. They haven't,
they haven't deemed him. He's done
with that. Like you've cured it.
Like if you get chested for chicken pox
and it comes up negative, they've cured.
You have chicken pox, polio, polio,
negative guy. Me The only person,
me cure of HIV. There's one more
guy now. I got one more guy now.
So what happened in this guy yet? Stem
cell treatment is what wo fixed it.
They're holding this stuff
from us. Yeah. They just had,
they just cured another guy, I
want to say a months back as it was
this year.
They did it while there was something
and I posted it on my Twitter feed that
apparently is an older store.
It's from like two years ago and it was
kind of from like a click baity type
site and it has a cool headlines,
but it was about how a guy was paralyzed
and he's got regaining use of his legs
because the stem cells. Really? Yeah.
I don't know enough about it. Look,
if that's true, that'd be fucking
incredible. I don't know that from people.
Yeah. I don't know enough about how
severe the injury was versus, you know,
cause I knew,
I do know that some people get temporarily
paralyzed by certain injuries and I
knew a dude who got slammed on his
head and his whole body went nominee,
couldn't move his body and he was like,
Oh my God, I'm paralyzed. This is a,
this is it. This is how I'm Lilla
for now on. I can't move my body.
But then his body slowly started coming
back and he just got jolted cause he was
wrestling like a Stinger. Yeah, he
was wrestling landed on his head.
[inaudible] scary fucking shit
man. Yeah, I mean parallels,
I mean paralyze and yeah,
full blown aids. Yeah.
So I don't know if they really
can bring someone back from that,
but man, if they can't hold shit. That's
a great question though, by the way,
that because they do say
if he's HIV negative,
they wouldn't say he's cured of it. Right.
So then evidently does show up in some
testing somewhere. Scientists, sorry,
we're sorry. Also, how was the, Oh,
how was he the only NBA
player in history to have HIV?
Do you remember Keenan? Every Wayne's
bit about them. No, I'm not Keenan.
I'm sorry. Damon [inaudible]
a bit about them. Damon, who?
I sing his praises often on this podcast
and he's like the most underrated
comedian of all time. I hear that often
by the way, rates one of the grades,
but he had a bit about,
nobody wanted to cover magic
Johnson except for Dennis Rodman.
Dennis rob was like, I fucked Madonna.
I'll spit in your mouth and
accelerate your symptoms.
Me is one of those
jokes where you hear it,
you can't fucking believe he said it
and you are on the floor slapping the
ground and you're like, no, no, no.
I mean he was a monster
monster by the way. Yeah,
I remember like fusion form like a year
or two ago. He was years ago actually.
Yeah. He just raided. People forgot.
It's like that Roy Jones Jr Shaw Song.
Y'All must've forgot. He
should put a special out there.
Maybe that's what he did. He should
put a special out. It always is.
It comes up pretty great too. He
like, he took a long time doing that.
That TV show. That's what it was.
People associated them
with that television show,
which was like very family
friendly, you know, good for him.
Made a lot of money, I'm sure.
Did you ever guess though,
is that what you're mad about? No,
no. I don't matter about anything.
I love that guy. I love his brother
too. Keenan's cool shit. Yeah.
Keene is like other ones against
Sean tomorrow. I know them.
Those don't know them as well.
Yeah, Keenan, super cool.
He's always been like a real
Downer with guy too. But uh,
I mean they have comedy bones, like
all these guys. I mean, like I,
I worked with Marlon and he is like,
he is so funny. He's hilarious.
The whole family. I mean, imagine a
family that does that much standup.
And I mean that's banana. I mean
the rock family too. Yes, yes.
Jordan and Tony and obviously Chris.
Yeah, Dude. Tony's another one.
God Damn, that Dude's funny. God Damn.
He's funny. I've never seen him love,
but he's, I only get told I look like
him, Bro. He's one of those guys that it,
because he's Chris Rock's
brother. People almost like, uh,
they look almost look past him. You know,
like, Oh, you're Chris Rock's brother.
The other rock like, dude, forget
all that. That guy's a murderer.
He fucking kills. He's really
good. He's just funny man.
He's just, and he's, it's like
sharp good writing, you know,
good solid punch lines and
boom, boom, boom is pacing.
He's like a legit killer. He's
a legit killer dude. He was,
the last time I saw him was in,
he was in the main room and the comic
store and there was, I walked into the,
to the back because there was rowers
and it was Tony Rocks and Tony Rock was
murdering. I mean,
murdering where hall's, oof.
Damn. You could hear it
in the hallway. That row,
that hallway roar when someone just
really hits a high note. I walked in like,
damn, no dude, everybody's always
talking about Tony Rock in the community.
I mean, he's, he's a
monster. Some monster.
I gotta check on me so much more famous
if he wasn't Chris Rock's brother.
But really you believe that 100%
he's, he's a fucking top 10 murderer.
I think that it's one of those things
that if your brother is one of the
greatest comics of all
time, not just a great car,
like your brother's Chris Rock.
Yeah. N****s, which is black people.
I mean everybody knows that, but
everybody knows that, but he,
he's one of the greats of all
time. If that's your brother. Oh,
people don't want to pay attention to
it. You know, it's a weird thing, man.
They just like, Hey, can you get me your
brother's number? You know what I mean?
It's like the gift and the
curse though. Yeah. So,
but I'm Tony Rog and I killed
two. I'll probably kill, you know,
Charlie used to have a been [inaudible]
Charlie used to have videos here he
goes, they said, Charlie do get mad
at people yelling out Charlie Murphy,
you know, cause everybody's
like Johnny Man. Hey,
that was like a thing
people would do with them.
If you're hanging out
with Charlie, he goes, no,
I'm just glad they're not calling
me Eddie Murphy's brother anymore.
Imagine how Ray j feels. Yeah, man.
Brandy's brother. And you know,
you never saw the tape. I did.
Did you? You saw the tape? Yeah.
Everybody had to see that. Yeah. It
was most watched TV. That's, yeah.
It's super important.
Isn't pub culture star?
You know, it's a, it's gotta be weird,
man. To have someone like that,
that's a brother that's, uh,
a person who's like, like if you're
Mike Tyson's brother, you know,
real good heavyweight boxer, Tony Tyson,
and that'll be your Mike Tyson's
brother and you can like,
I can knock out stu like,
Eh, like Mike Rowe. Yeah.
He is judged at a totally
different standard,
but I don't think that's the
case with the Waynes brothers.
The Waynes brothers is like generally
accepted that they're all really talented,
you know? Yeah. And they're,
yeah. They're all really good.
They're all super successful. Yeah. Yeah.
Kim Too. Yeah. All of them now. Yeah.
Shawntay like, yeah. Damian, all those
crazy comedy family Craig. Yeah. Yeah.
They're all just like, it's just, it's
in their DNA predisposed to being funny.
Well, it's also like that's the
family business, which is, you know,
some people they make boots,
right, where they cater, you know,
or they want Delis. A man. I
was just in Italy like the,
like when you see like these
little small family businesses,
small family restaurants, like people
that work there, you know the likes.
Like the father's the owner and the
daughter's the manager mom works in the
kitchen. It's like, wow, this is crazy.
But they still do that. Businesses.
Yeah, that was always a thing. Right?
You remember like family businesses on
the east coast now it's like so rare that
people, they wear it like
a badge of honor. Look,
it's a family business to be family
businesses know that everything went
corporate though. Yeah, man.
There's certain places where
that's not the case though.
Like you got to really appreciate because
one of the things you appreciate about
going to Italy, there's this
like a bunch of little places.
I mean they have nice stores,
like if you're in like Gucci Shit and
stuff like that. They have nice stores,
but the restaurants and all the places
where you buy things, they're not like,
they're like people shops, they're not
boutiques. They're just like, yeah,
I go to, I go to Craig's or I go to, yeah,
Tiffany skit or Walgreens or
you know, or Sears. It's not,
there's no corporate to
to it. It's just families.
It's weird. Like keeps the money in
the household. You know what I mean?
That makes a real familial app
actually works out, but which isn't,
that makes sense. And
that's also why I say like,
I'm not real big into the reparations
talk for black people. I mean,
I didn't really know the ins and
outs of it. People keep saying like,
we needed get ready for Twitter.
Hey, I'm saying this. I'm saying,
how about we incentivize parenting?
Hmm, okay, but can you do that?
Let's keep, if if you're watching
your kids instead of like,
they're just out there to me, like
let's say it's reparations. Talk about,
I don't know, infrastructure in black
communities. And if that's the case,
well then let's incentivize
keeping the parents there,
keeping the parents together,
or if they're split up,
it's just like if you guys are teaching
your kid and he and he's in school every
day or he survived, you know,
eight years of the school shooting,
every family gets like, you know,
a big bonus, you know? Or if,
if he makes the honor roll, you
know, like you guys get this,
it's like you'd really be investing
in your investments like it take,
they say it takes 18 years to make
back on your investment of your child.
If you're, if you're incentivizing
them to go to school for education,
it's gonna make better people in a
better society. That seems good on paper.
Now if you're seeing incentivize
like how to incentivize them, right?
I'm saying like, oh,
it's good, it's all good.
It's always good to encourage
people to be successful.
So your kid test well on some of
these like aptitude tests, right?
Then you get a stipend or something
like that. I mean he's like, wait,
what are these reparations we're
talking about? Exactly. Because exactly.
I don't really know
the ins and outs of it,
but if it's about infrastructure of
black communities, I'm so into it.
But it's also, let's
incentivize, keep it, you know,
that being in the child's life,
because for a lot of the upper,
a lot of the reasons kids are like,
they're depressed and they feel like they
have a chip on their shoulder because
nobody's home watching them and they go
to these gangs. Did they go deal with
these other things right now because
they're just not being watched. Right.
But I think the idea behind reparations
is that some people at one point in time
were profiting off of slavery.
Those people have used that money and
that money is become a part of really
large businesses. Many, many large
businesses taking from businesses. Well,
that's where reparations would have
to come from in my house. Yeah. Yeah.
General Electric. Fucking give me $1,500.
That's one that I think directly
should be like, you have to wonder,
like if you made, like what
have you used to sell babies,
right? And you had a baby selling
business, you sold babies, right?
And then uh, your,
your grandson inherited all
your money from selling babies,
but the grandson is
cool. I mean he just, uh,
he goes coffin and he's not
criminal or it's fine, it's fine.
But is it fine because didn't his money
come from babies? Helen, where's it,
where, wait a minute, let's trace this
money. Like here's, it started out,
it was this much money and then your
dad got that and then his dad got that.
And then like how many generations?
So you're saying that families who are
known plantation owners should have to
pay that money back to the black
community. Where did it go?
Where'd the money go? What was
he used for? No, you're right.
A hundred years ago. It's 1865.
Okay. It's not that long ago.
It's so recent to anybody that's on the
census that says they're black. Right?
Like an 8%. If I'm 80% black, I'm going
to get how much of this, you know,
the Jones plantation, you know,
fortune. I'm not saying that.
I'm saying that what the,
the smart thing to do would to
be to figure out what damage was.
Like if they really objectively looked
at what damage was done to communities
where slavery existed for,
I mean how many hundreds of years in
this country before it was 400 years.
Hundreds of years. Right.
And then it ends and then these people
live in these cities and they're
discriminated against and they're locked
up. They would, they would sort of,
one thing that I learned about who
was telling us about this, that they,
they would disproportionately arrest
glowed man [inaudible] them the worst air
for black people in America.
It's not so much slavery as it is the
reconstruction air because then people are
just mad that black people are here.
Yeah. But they were also arresting them.
Small crimes and making them work
in prison. Kidnapping people. Yeah.
Megan indentured servants. You become,
it's just another form of slavery.
It's like through his weird loophole,
like you could make you a slave again.
We just arrest you for hanging out in
the street and then we put you in this
factory. And you have to do
this for us and make nothing.
And it's basically the
same thing as slave,
but when you find out what they make
in prisons, when you go, wait a minute,
they, they work for like 13 cents a
day or whatever the fuck they get.
Like what they figured out how to,
yeah, they're modernizing slavery. Yeah,
because somehow or another that's okay
because we've got them locked in a box.
Like they're supposed
to be punished. Right.
They're supposed to be rehabilitated
and take it off the street,
but we're going to make them work for
no money. I know white man is so smart.
Why don't we like black guys? We got
to start making white guys work for us.
Why don't we do the same thing?
We're just a smart, well,
those all the areas that were affected
by that in the fifties and sixties
there's a residual effect
that is never been addressed.
Like the government has never said,
we've got to figure out how to make
these spots better because the reason why
they're so fucked up is because slavery
was there and then the subsequent,
yeah,
the race riots of the 60s and the this
quest to to figure out what to do with
those sort of stopped short.
There's not like a like,
like Baltimore and places like that,
like Detroit south side Chicago
were just murdered every year.
We just accept that the numbers,
high numbers of murder. Right.
Is West side of Chicago,
is that where it all goes down
there just really poor areas,
but it's also like how did these guys
getting guns yet if you can drive around,
you can get a gun and that's
another, yeah, I just don't know.
Like you have money for guns, but
you'd have money to like, I don't know,
you know, get a backpack and go to school.
Well also if you see that
around you all the time,
the problem is you become a part of
that world. If everyone's Kinda gun,
never been shooting at everybody and
don't know, you better get one better.
Get a fucking gun, I'm going to try to
shoot at you. You got to shoot back.
Like what? Like they're still shooting
like, yeah, you live in a war zone, bro.
Go get the gun. That's what
it is. It's an it just like,
it's not a war zone in terms of like
it's official resume declaration by the
government, but it's a war
zone. These are undeclared wars.
People are shooting at each other that's
say, yeah, they're warring each other.
[inaudible] and McCoy is a, it's
a war. It's a civil war. This is,
it's like warring tribes. If we have
that in fucking Siberia right now,
I bet. I bet the Siberian
gang fights. Yeah,
but that's also the to every
best depression and that's,
that's another thing classism does.
It's like they're telling you to kill
yourself because you're just poor and you
don't know what to do. And it's
like, but that's not true. I mean,
I'm a black guy like you guys. And I
got, I got family members who were,
you know, in gangs like that
and it sucks down there.
They're so depressed
because they, what they say?
They don't know how to get out of it
and you don't see any pathway and they
don't see anybody who's gotten out of
it, so they feel like they're stuck.
There's a lot of kids that grow up in
bad situations. They feel inferior.
Exactly. And yeah,
they feel inferior because of the
clothes they wear or how much money their
family has or within. How do you
empower those parents through,
I think through activities.
I think I'm getting those kids involved
in things that they can get good at,
that show that they have value and
that with hard work comes rewards.
I mean,
some of the greatest success stories in
this country are professional athletes
coming out of impoverished neighborhoods
and they become these global superstar,
but then they stay in there, but then
they stay in their kids' lives though,
don't they? Some of them do,
yeah. I mean, they're still there,
but it's like you can't, you
can't fix all that's taken place.
No, you have to sort of figure out how to,
how to improve the way
people look at life,
the way people interface with life. It's
very hard if you're trying to do that,
but all around you as violence and crime
and fear and your cortisol levels are
all jacked up because
you're in the hood and that,
that's not been addressed like a
serious health problem in this country.
This like even an infrastructure problem.
We just sort of accept the fact is,
and this is your problem, so if
we're going to put money back,
if we're going to operate, if we're
going to repair these black communities,
put money in the infrastructure,
but also you've got incentives to
incentivize parents to be there.
I think it's a good idea.
I like what you're saying because
you're not punishing them. No,
just incentivize. I'm not saying like
we shouldn't get money, you know,
just for being black.
I'm saying we got to keep the parents
there because that's what builds a strong
community. It really does. You know,
I don't know a whole lot about common
law Harris, but, uh, I do know that, um,
you know, she's a very
powerful, well-spoken lady,
but she was talking once about this
thing that they did where they had these
parents, um,
be responsible for their kids
truancy and so they could go to jail.
Like the idea was, I make sure this
is correct. Make sure is correct,
Jamie, because I think the thing
they were saying was they were,
they were gonna they would have cops
go to visit when a kid would had been
truant. Okay.
And they would sort of threaten the
mother that she's responsible for the
child's truancy. The mother
is not the father. Well,
whoever was there a single
mother in this case of this one,
one case they were talking
about specifically and that
this lady had to figure
out a way to get her fucking son
to show up at school. Hey, I'm,
I could go to jail, you know, and
did it work? I'm sure it worked,
right? I'm sure everyone
was probably terrified.
But is that really what
we want in America?
We want people to be scared that you
might go to jail if your kid doesn't go to
school. So if the kid
doesn't go to school,
you're going to lock someone in a
cage that is so threatening. Yeah.
Cause that's also homeschool.
You know what I mean?
I mean just cause he's enrolled.
It's almost like, you know,
maybe I took a sick day, but if
you want to do homeschooling thing,
I think you have to fill out
paperwork. You apply for it.
They'll have to let them know
that you're withdrawing your test.
And the school says, I think, but
how many trophies is this? Is this,
this first one? I don't know how you
know your first time offender camera.
It was a hundred someone saying they're
gonna lock you in jail cause your kid
doesn't go to school. That's
bananas. That's bananas like you,
he's 16 or whatever the
fuck. It's like when are you,
when you were 16 you were free.
Like I was a latchkey kid
when I was 14 I was out gone.
We lived in different time though, Joe.
I know Bruno. We had to sue genders,
you know, racist race. You
know, it's different for us.
It's that the only thing that bothers
me does that just drives me crazy. The,
the, the, the idea of like,
the way you fix things is by
scaring people and locking them.
That's how religion gulags start, man.
That's, that's really, that's how,
that's how the Soviet Union becomes this
really fucking empire of authoritarian
regime. Let's up the,
the jail sentences of some parents
in multiple counties were in quotes,
what she said, an unintended
consequence of a statewide law.
But I'm looking further into this and uh,
this says this is from Los Angeles time.
What was that speech actually that
she gave where she explained how she,
how she did it and how it was effective.
She was hard on people being truant.
I think your idea, what my point was,
I think that your idea is better because
instead of punishing people for not
doing, it incentivizes them for
doing it. And if you could set aside,
imagine that as a project, right?
You were saying that like it takes 18
years to see if we could fund an 18 year
project where they were doing that and
just incentivizing kids to succeed and
all of a sudden they can just
start succeeding like crazy.
Like what if we had a big jump
because it was like financially vital,
like you're competing
for what's a great idea.
It's a great competing look
for money you like, by the way,
look at all these guys who could get
popped in a in college for like taking,
you know, incentives.
It's like it's because they're getting
their parents jobs or homes or cars.
There's another form. There's
another form. I know what I mean.
College athletes who's getting
fucked harder than college athletes.
Exactly. Who's getting fucked harder than,
the only thing that's
interesting about the,
I mean literally only thing that's
interesting about the event is to athletes
performing. That's it. And
they make own gods. They make,
not that they're getting
to 40 grand scholarship.
I'll give you the opportunity
to perform you right.
The way that everybody gets here, like
get an electrical engineering degree.
Like everybody wants me. What are
you talking about? I'm like, God,
look at this. 2016 2017 school year,
the NCAA revenue reached 1 billion with
a B $1 billion and they're a nonprofit,
right? Athletes get one gots to get
paid to organize this sports defense.
Really Click on that link. It
says, Eh, NCAA sports make one.
That's that business insiders,
that's one of them. Real quick.
Baity is that like a, is
it or is it a real legit,
you just got to figure
out who wrote the article,
but it's also like what California is
like. Did they put on a bill? Right?
They're going to pay the
athletes for their likeness.
They should pay him to play Chopin
play. What are the three schools?
I think those people
in the audience would,
they pay for the pay for entertainment.
They're paying to watch the entertainment
depending on watch the game.
So how come the players don't get a
piece? Right? Why don't they do it?
But it's like [inaudible]
it says my name on the back,
like why can't I get just like a piece
of that? The idea is that it's not fair.
No one else gets anything for
anything they do in school.
But that's you're stealing from athletes.
You're professional cause you're getting
paid for your, for your craft. No.
Well then if it's going to be the
athletes going to work for free,
the fucking show should be
free. It should be free tickets.
[inaudible] just broke the Internet.
That's what it should be like. Oh, okay.
We don't get any money. Well,
you don't get any money either.
We're doing it for fun or
you're doing it for fun.
What do we need to have games?
We're free. Yeah. Holy Shit.
That's how it should be.
You don't want to pay me
free. Everything's free.
You can't charge money and keep it all
you greedy. That'd be the worst audience.
By the way. The free audience is the
worst audience don't want, you know,
the weird thing about colleges is the
dudes who have graduated and they're rich
now and they did. They donate money.
Keep that football program alive.
They give you a fucking status thing
in their community player. Love it.
Like Jamie loves Columbus teams. Anything
from Columbus, he gets a boner for,
he gets super [inaudible]. Oh wait,
from this one watching
the basketball tournament,
there's stuff going on at Ohio
state with the Epstein Shit.
They've invested a lot of money at Ohio
state and they're trying to figure out
if they need to give it back or not
only did he go to Ohio state, he didn't,
but he's involved in Columbus business
and so they have given a lot of money to
this football team. And have they
determined that his, um, that his money,
like how his money was made
through sex trafficking,
like Epstein's money? Yeah.
I don't know. I don't know.
I mean I know he's managing that one guys.
I mean how much from sex trafficking?
Cause I thought man, that would make
him a plantation owner, like in a sense,
right. Because he's like,
he's given up flesh. He's get,
he's getting paid for flush.
[inaudible] what was his, is allegedly,
what he did was he would find young girls
and get them to give them massages and
they'd be like, you guys should, you
know yeah. Getting my tribe. Yeah.
The prosecutor and I were like, oh man.
[inaudible] a real creepy
way of describing it too.
He said that he thought it was
impossible for him to control that his,
his impulses were impossible for him to
control and he was a great flight risk.
So he didn't want him to
have um, chief, that's true.
So his therapist was saying this,
so they're trying to protect him but it's
also like are they trying to cure him?
I think see if that quote is true
cause uh, I'm pretty high right now.
The prosecutor said that he uh,
Dyson that the Epstein fellow had 'em
impulses that were impossible to control
that that's how he felt. But a lot
of those guys, I say that right.
Even like the Jared and all the guys
say that that's a thing apparently about
pedophiles is that the recidivism
rates so high when they get,
if they do go to jail and then they
get released, boy man they do it again.
Cause like I got away. I can do
that. I can deal with this. Dan,
I think they're broken. I
think it's like a, like,
you know that screen that was just all
fucked up and that's them. It's a glitch.
Yeah. I think, I don't think we
should assume that, you know, if you,
if your brain is working well
when your body's working well,
you just can't assume that everybody's
is. And I think some people,
but there's also like, you feel bad for
it. I mean, like we feel guys who like,
who are born with maybe like
severe cerebral palsy, right?
Like in a sense that's what's
happening to them. You know, like they,
they can't control this
urge, but then it's also,
how do you fix that instead of like
shaming them right in. And a lot of it is,
apparently a lot of pedophilia is brought
from through sexual trauma, right?
So if someone is molested
as a young child,
apparently there's a high likelihood
that they're going to do it.
Their likelihood rather, that they
can. So it's like the HIV virus, it's,
it's just you're, you're
breaking someone's wiring,
like the wiring to the way they
interface with the world as a young age,
at a young age. And you're fucking
up their life in a horrible way.
And they say that about Michael
Jackson. Right. He's like,
he got touched earlier. Then it was
like he just, he was using that as like,
Hey, I, this is, this is normal to me.
Why did he ever allege happened to him?
Did he ever explain what
happened to him? No.
There was something where he was talking
about how he had all the surgeries so
he didn't have to look like his
father. I remember that. Really? Yeah.
But that's also, it could also be that.
So he was scared of his father. Yeah.
And every time I look in the mirror, he
saw his father. Yeah. Man in the mirror.
Yeah. And look, that's what it's about.
I don't think that it's
not about show shit.
It's about getting your shit
together. They also say,
they also say because he
bought the Beatles catalog
that that's a smear campaign
and like they pay those kids off to
say that about them. That's ridiculous.
It's a great conspiracy theory.
I think people are, um, you know,
they're crazy if they think it's normal
for a guy to have a bunch of kids sleep
in his bed. And he was weird.
You know my cousin drugs that is
off the charts.
Bananas that anybody would let their
kids stay there off the charts. Bananas.
It is also, Mike was off the charts. Yeah.
I mean he had so many hits.
The more hits you have,
the more shit you can get away
with until we didn't. Okay.
Berman's dis dismissed the request for
bail because Epstein's impulses are not
likely to have abated or been successfully
suppressed. That's not exactly,
I definitely, that makes more
sense. I paraphrased hard.
That's how things get Florida
guns. How rumors get started.
So this is in Florida. You can
get away with anything there.
He used to be able to either tighten
it down on Florida. Thank God.
What the fuck? Florida 2019
it took you this long. Well,
Florida was the place where the pain
pill mills existed with the have the
management centers,
the pain management centers right
next to an oxycontin store too.
So you go to the doctor. It's just my
back's killing me. The doctor's like,
you need pain pills. I do need pain
pills and just write a piece of paper.
And then you would literally
go to the next door over,
and it was the building connected
to them that sells the pain pills.
They'd have it in the same spot. Sometimes
it's just like cocaine country too,
right? Yeah. Everybody's so fucking
high in Florida. Oh Dude, Florida.
It's crazy. It's crazy. It's got a
history of high. I feel like the,
the chaos of the 80s of all the cocaine
is burned into the psyche of the
landmass. And then the alligators moved
in and made it even more reptilian.
Cause if I was a kid that was made
up more reptilian when I was a kid,
I lived there. I lived in
Israel, I lived in Gainesville,
Gainesville north. I don't
know if it's nor is it north,
sort of [inaudible] medalist,
but in the middle. Okay.
I mean we were around alligators,
but they were endangered back then.
So they would tell her, yeah, they
thought of them as endangered.
People are so silly. They're like,
we have to protect these fucking
that are around us. We have to.
And when I was there, uh, some
ladies poodle got snatched.
I think it was a poodle.
It was a small dog got snatched by
an alligator while I was there. Yeah.
Yeah. I didn't see it happen,
but I came like after it happened and
people were all freaked out and uh,
they were, uh, telling you to
stop feeding the marshmallow.
We would feed alligators marshmallow
and they'd keep coming back. Well,
the thing is they would, they
liked the marshmallows like,
so you knew if you threw the marshmallows,
the alligator come up and eat it.
And uh, they got used to eating
marshmallows and then there was signs,
they said,
don't have the alligators eat marshmallows
because it's apparently bad for the
digestive system and blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. Like a shit everywhere.
Your mother can eat a
whole dog with Colorado.
That's better for that judges
there. They, yeah, I mean,
it's not digested the dog's collar.
It's swallowing that collar.
It's gonna shit out
that metal buckle. Ugh.
You really think I'm
marshmallows going to start.
And so this attitude that they had that
they wanted to bring back the alligator,
it was a good thing. Cause you know they
really were on the verge of extinction,
but then it became the opposite.
So now alligators are everywhere.
So now like alligators, people
find them in their house,
they find them in their pool.
Like they're snatching people up
like red some New York or they're
everywhere. And they're so,
did you see that one that was really
recently filmed walking across a golf
course? No, it is a dinosaur.
15 feet long. I do love the gator though.
I fucking love it. Really.
It's an awesome animal.
See if you could find the video, the
video of the giant alligator they,
and they said, by the way,
that this alligator is probably somewhere
in the neighborhood of 80 years old.
He's 80 years old looking at zero 80
years. That's an eight year old alligator.
God, he never experienced any
kind of racism or Jim Crow laws.
They're just walking through
[inaudible] machine, you know,
good for. But here it is. Look
at this. Oh Shit. You were alone.
Oh my God. Oh, he's 80 years old.
That's an 80 year old alligator.
He's moving kind of fresh. They'd
say the ones that are really big,
when they get to be that
like 15 foot length, he goes,
a lot of those are really old.
50 60 no arthritis. I mean God,
my friend shot one and it was more than
80 years old. Shout out to John Dudley
as a dinosaur. As a Goddamn
Blauer that means that is,
rewind that again because
we're both super high.
I mean that what is even doing mansion,
seeing that Brian Moses are
in your yard, you're chilling,
hanging out on your phone,
get your feet up and you see
that walking across your yard.
And I gotta get the fuck out of Florida
and be like, how close is that to me?
What the fuck? I mean that's,
it's super dope. Look,
I mean look at that thing and
he's got a scab there too.
How much do you think that
weighs? Let's go half a ton.
500 I
think a thousand. Easy. Cause you see
the guys fishing and the ones I am,
he's real in a big ass
fish. And the gator.
Once it starts chasing him on land and
these guys like get the fuck out of the
way, you know? Oh my God. 2000
pound gang big. But it's big.
It's a lot of church shoes. It's so big.
So a lot of church shoes, these things,
they live amongst us and they eat dogs
and they year and everything else.
They can get their hands.
They have to eat a lot of food to
maintain that fucking mass. Is this it?
So the guy, oh my God, he's got some what?
Somebody's always got closed in
the gators chasing him. Holy Shit.
Oh fuck man. Whoa.
How Agile is for 80 do they move
quick? They move quick. I don't know.
Who knows how old that one is?
That could be a younger one. Oh,
he's stealing this dude's
fish and keep the fish. Wow.
He just got jack. That does not
look good. Rocket dial. Yeah,
I was going to say that. It doesn't look
like an alligator. That's a crocodile.
What's the difference?
Crocodiles have like a pointing or
snout and they're way more aggressive.
Don't fuck with a cruck. Alligators are
better. Yeah. Oh my God, they're better.
If it was as many crocodiles as
there are alligators in Florida,
way more people would be getting
jacked. Oh, so crock is Olo crock.
So fuck everybody up.
Cross do not discriminate.
They get water buffaloes,
people, they don't give a fuck.
They're real aggressive too.
There was this one video of 'em.
They had like an alligator farm and they
were raising alligators and then they
had one crocodile and so when it came
time to feeding the one Crockett,
I was like, bitch down. Sit the fuck down.
Climbing on top of these egg
roosters and hens like, yeah,
but she was on the top of all the
alligators. Fuck the fuck off of here.
And just took control and it was
getting the food. Now we'll crop.
Will a crocodile eat to an
alligator? That's a good question.
They hate each other. Do they really
turn to Cayman? Where's the Cayman Fall?
It's a crocodile, but it's a very
small crocodile. Cayman's are small.
They live in the Amazon. Have you
eaten crocodile? No. Or gator? Yeah,
I'll get her. I was like,
how do I want a place?
It was like a fucking TGI Friday's
type joint and it wasn't the best,
wasn't TGI Fridays, but you know, it was
like one Applebee's type place. Right.
Like a chain. And it wasn't like fresh.
But apparently when you get it
fresh like right off the gator,
it's supposed to be really good.
Just like any meat can be like the,
you know what I mean? Even rat. Yeah.
But the alligator thing is like, oh,
did you eat the gator dude?
We went crazy. What a weekend.
No am I a, my brother and
sister lived down there and uh,
my brother got a gun pulled on him.
Whoa. But like a delivery driver. Whoo.
So there, so my brother,
they a little baby,
my little niece and a there with her is
my brother and her in the back and then
he's driving us in the neighborhood.
He's going the speed limit, right?
Like maybe like five to 10 miles
an hour, maybe a little slower.
And there's a delivery driver
behind him. Deliver driver gets mad,
starts honking at him,
is behind him. Right. Uh,
my brother in law pulls into
the driveway delivery driver,
pulls him behind him and is
like, what do you want to do man?
And flashes a gun on him. And my brother
brother's like, he's as big as you,
he's like a bodybuilder
and he's a, he was like,
I don't want to do anything man. He's, I
just wonder why you're honking. I mean,
like, I'm, I got my daughter
in the back, you know,
she's like less than a year
old. And the guy's just like,
I'm not making this a
race thing. And he's like,
I'm not saying this is a race thing and
[inaudible] yeah. So he's just like,
well, and it might, you
know, might cause my, uh,
my brother was in the military and
he could come calling the guy, sir.
And the guy's like, you call me sir,
get in the military. And he's just like,
I am sorry, I am in the
military. And he just like,
we get a disgrace to the
military and he's just like,
I just went slow enough
because my daughter's in the
back and you're behind me.
So he's like, I don't understand
what the deal is here.
And the guys was just kept just trying
to egg them on to try to like provoke a
fight because of stand your ground. Oh
yeah, I made, it was when I heard about,
I was terrified. My, my,
my sister was shocked.
She had to come home from
work because was like,
you know the baby's in the back and
this guy just like pulled up into your
driveway and he's just like,
if Quincy would've made a
move and that guy shot him,
that guy had been in the right.
How much of that's going on? That's
probably happening all the time.
Look web in the Trayvon,
that's a uniquely incompetent
security guard too though. I mean,
he was getting smashed.
He's getting his head bounced
off by 15 year old right now.
The kid was fucking him up when
he pulled that gun out. I mean
that happened to Florida too.
Wasn't that a a parking lot, right?
We're where a guy like thought he was
being threatened by a dude with his kids
in the car and then he shot the guy.
There's a parking lot in uh, in Florida.
I don't know that one. Well
that's where that, that I,
they haven't either last
year or something, but that,
that's definitely a recent one.
People just haven't guns all the
time. Seems like a great idea.
But the people like that having
guns. Yeah, it becomes a problem.
And somebody that somebody knows that you
don't have a gun and they're trying to
go do you into something so they could
shoot you like a fucking outlaw Josie
Wales movie. Like that's not
someone defending themselves.
So that's the weapon.
That's why guns are creepy. It's not
creepy because a guy like you has a gun,
which I'm, you're a great guy.
You're not gonna rob anybody. No,
I don't need a gun. You
wouldn't have a gun. Right.
But if you hit did have a gun, I
wouldn't be nervous. I'd been like, well,
Moses has a gun. He can handle it.
And I'm not looking at people
that aren't good guys. Right.
And if those good not good guys get a gun.
This is the one who's talking about
where the guys said big standard group in
case we just like on the ground with
his hands up and he's got shots still
really, like I said, he was felt
threatened or something. I believe
that's all they need is a reason to.
That's all they need is a reason.
The Florida, he's on the ground
on his knees and the guy shot him.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ. I mean,
when do you not shoot someone if there
are, if, if you're sh you're willing,
are you willing to shoot
at me? They flattened out.
Like did he have to fuck that? It was
always like, if somebody is attacking you,
I thought, I mean that's your, that's
your on the offense flat now. Like,
no, you have to offer them
money. Please don't here.
Here's how much I think my
life. Would you accuse him?
I mean if he shot the guy while
was the guy was flattened out.
What about that do you think the same.
The beam, you know what I'm saying?
Like do you think like they'd have the
same reaction cause the reaction they had
when they saw him with his hands
up on his [inaudible] be mad. Yeah.
I don't know how mad you get. Oh, I
don't know how mad you are with a gun.
You're hit with a weapon in
your hand to be like, I can,
I'm playing God run out of this guy.
I can kill this man right now with
this person right here. Right. So yeah,
it wouldn't matter what they accuse him.
What I'm saying is what they accused
him because they didn't, he got away.
He got away with it. Right.
He was accused of it. Right.
It wasn't charged for this. They didn't
charge him. That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
What? That's what I'm saying.
The guy that shot it wasn't arrested
yet. He's deciding stand your ground law.
I'm reading right here from the AP
Sheriff won't arrest parking lot shooter.
That's all. So they can't even charge
him. No, that's what I'm saying.
That's a charge like a, that's
like you can't challenge that rule.
Like in football, you can't,
that's not he a red flag.
He said he felt threatened in
the black. I was just like, dude,
I was on the ground and there's, there's,
there's closed circuit footage of it.
Yep. My question was what if
he had lied down, lie down,
flat on the ground with then he
be, I mean, when would they, what?
What would the line be where
they decide to charge him?
You know what I'm saying?
When he's on his knees. Okay.
Will you charge him with his lying
down? Like the guy's lying down.
Just execute him. Is that
still stand your ground there?
There is a manslaughter trial apparently
now updated 18 manslaughter. Oh,
he killed that guy. Try to
call the sheriff as a defense
witness. That's insane.
Insane. There's certain people
that should never gun right now.
There's certain people, a lot of you know,
seasoned law enforcement people and
people with good dispositions that would
never in their fucking wildest dreams
shoot someone who was on their knees would
never threaten anybody with a gun and
they have a gun purely for sense for
self-defense. That's a
different thing. You know,
but when you have everybody
can have a gun that's,
you're going to get a certain number
of those fucking guys and they think,
wait a minute, they think
they're in the right eye. Yeah.
I think we all got to get guns.
I mean like, is that not the,
it's not that the move. We know
we'll get guns. This is America.
We can be racist and have
guns and be on drugs.
Well you have to be on
drugs now. It's new.
There's gonna it's gonna come to
a point like, could you imagine?
How scared are you of your kids to go
to school now? That's scary. Scared.
When you have children, you're very
vulnerable. You know, you feel, um,
you feel more filled with
love than ever before,
but you also feel more feel with fear
cause you're, you're worried. I mean,
that's one of the things
that the Romans always knew.
So make people have families. You can
control them if they have families.
Oh that's fucking powerful.
Yeah, you can control,
you can't control young dudes who were
saying those with swords or single.
You want them to get shacked up and have
kids when they stopped that way. Yeah.
And then you gotta kill somebody kids
every now and then keep them in line.
Jesus, Joe did Brown. I
mean that's what they did.
They did that from time honored
tradition. You killed somebody,
a kid to keep them in line for, they did
it with, they've done it in the Mafia.
They've done it with a lot
of people. I mean it's,
it's always been something that
people do to put fear in people.
You get people to when you have a lot
more to lose when you have a family,
they look at it that way. There's
certain people that, I mean,
when you study how to get people to
listen to you and to behave and how to
strike fear in the populace, that's why,
that's why they don't want abortion laws.
[inaudible]
wow. That's deep right dish. If,
if there is someone that
is really thinking we need,
we need to make sure that people
have families so that they'll be more
vulnerable. Yeah. If there is someone
that is following that philosophy,
which is not my thought. Yeah, exactly.
You said the Romans said that, but it's,
it's been around forever.
This is like a commonly like a human
human humans born. They think that like,
oh we have to keep
families, get them in line.
Well it's when you talk about the
authoritarian authoritarian figures,
like people that want to have an
iron fist control the population.
The last thing you want is a bunch of
young single guys running around with no
attachments because that's how coups
get successfully completed. Yeah.
He's young mercenaries just decided to
take over your fucking building like
spendable style and shoot everybody.
You don't want that because they
have nothing to lose. Right.
He wanted a guy who loves his
wife and he's got his kids and he,
you know he's got, yeah, he's
got something to lose and that's,
that's how you keep a society in order
and that's why you shouldn't be getting
rid of babies. No condoms, no
babies, no birth control, no babies.
If someone really was plotting
out a culture that way,
like really masterminding
it and really saying that,
not just knowing that if that is the
case that people do change when they have
children,
but then doing this and promoting this
on purpose specifically to control
people. If that was the case, yeah, they
would do that. They would do that too.
They would, they would,
they would work against abortion because
they would want more people to have
more kids so that they can control
them. That makes sense. Well good.
It's crazy. So crazy to think that way.
But it would only be like one factor.
I think the major factor is
religion because if you are, um,
if you are pro-life and a candidate
is a pro choice in your mind,
a lot of times people decide that,
that that person is
against like God's law.
That person wants to kill children, right.
So they almost feel like compelled devote,
yeah.
You know, to, to vote against
you if you're pro choice.
But like are they thinking
about, well, you know,
what did this mother doesn't raise this
child? Now you have this, you know,
this mother who's resentful
of this child that she had,
that you guys made her have [inaudible]
and this child who's, you know,
this loveless child now and they both,
you know, she's got mental illness,
he's got mental illness because you
know, he's looking for his mother's love.
She's like, this kid wrote my dreams,
you know, this husband didn't stay,
that kind of thing. And you're just,
you're, you're making these communities,
you know, depressed and sad, you
know, and then you guys, you said, no,
you have to have that. You're
not raising this kid. You know,
you don't put money in that, you
know, and this, this family's pocket.
All these things you're
saying are true. Yeah.
It's one of those things where you
could see two to like distinct patterns,
but infinite different
varieties of completely the
world sucks because the baby
was born or the world is amazing. Right?
The baby's born. Tim Tebow says that,
you know, he's, that's the thing, man.
It's true. Tim. He goes, awesome. True.
I mean it's, you never
know. You never know.
But it's whose decision should it be?
And what is it? That's the real question.
Like what is abortion,
right? Like what is it?
Is it killing a baby or is it a medical
procedure? Like which one is it? Oof.
And as a slippery slope,
that's where the debate falls in pro
choice or pro choice or pro life.
It's not that these pro choice
people are evil people. No,
they just don't want anybody dictating.
I mean signed like an evil organization
that's created by Satan. It's not,
it's not.
It's women that don't want you to tell
them what to do with their reproductive
system. That's what it is. They want to
be able to make the choice themselves.
But then there's other people that
are pro life and specifically the more
militant ones, which you know, have
a assassinated abortion doctors.
I mean there are,
there are people that firmly believed
that even if it's just a couple of days
old, right, it's a baby. Right.
And that any sort of procedure to
stop that in its place is murder.
You're murdering a baby and there's
no if, ands, or buts about it.
And it's like the way they look at
the loony laughed and that they,
they buy into this
bullshit and you know that,
that that's a narrative that, you know,
that's how they, that's
how they really believe.
And people demonize people on both sides
of it as if they're so different and
there's no way you could ever think any
differently the way than the way you're
thinking it right now. No, I think you,
you broke it down just like is that a
medical procedure or is it the other way?
And I think that's a, that's that's
hard to get into that you can't,
I mean that's, that will be
debating that til the end of time.
Well it's one of the most human subjects
because it shows how complicated shit
really is. And if you
try to pretend it's not,
then you get into late term abortions.
And I'm like, well, what's up there?
When, when does it get weird
for you? When is six months?
Does it get weird then? Look, it's weird.
Like, I'm not saying you should be,
it shouldn't be able to have
an abortion or should be,
I'm not saying either of those things.
I'm just saying to deny
the weirdness at the very,
the nicest term that I could come up
with weirdness. Right. It is weird.
I had a, I got a girl pregnant, I was a
teenager and, uh, she had an abortion,
I'm sorry. She had a miscarriage,
nature's abortion. And then, uh, she, uh,
she would,
I was eight weeks or nine weeks and she
was flushing out chunks of who she was
calling the baby. So I mean, that's at
like eight to nine weeks. Everybody.
Jesus. Crazy. So wow. And she
shouldn't have had a baby.
She was on crystal meth. I mean,
that, that shouldn't have happened.
So thank whatever. Higher power
did that for us. But um, yeah,
that's what I'm saying. Like that.
I mean, that's what you're saying.
That's why it's so messy and it really
is messy because you don't know what is
what. Right. You know, she's like,
it traumatized her. Yeah. You know,
makes sense.
I mean a crazy process that the human
body goes through that men will never
really understand because there's never
going to been going to be an opportunity
where a body grows inside your body
and then comes out of your body,
the way a woman experiences.
And that's mainly it. Shit Dude.
Women experience something that
is so alien to anything that the,
that males experience that grow a
body inside of them. Yeah, it's very,
it's so different. We're
so deep. It's so different.
Like in terms of how they interface
with the world. They have to nurturing.
They want to protect the Nast and keep
everybody safe and they're going to have
a baby inside boom.
And now they have to take care of this
baby and care for and then the baby will
become more people and they'll start
mating and they get become adults and they
[inaudible] earthlings. Y comes
out of their body. And for us, man,
we just, we just shoot loads. So
easy. This is like what the art,
what we do when we don't have a baby and
what we do when we have a baby is the
exact same thing like you to when you
have sex with a woman and she gets
impregnated, it's,
it feels like regular sex to us and we
have sex all the time and you don't get
pregnant and then all of a sudden
you are. So it's like weird.
Like we didn't even do anything. We
just had sex. Like we normally have sex,
we had sex, and now there's an ex, an
extra person. Like Whoa, like why? It's,
but there's a lot of times because you
say you associate sex with pleasure,
like it is obviously, but when
you have a baby you're like, oh,
it does that. Does that. Yes, it
does. Yeah. Does that, so for a man,
there's no, there's no difference
in what happens to his body, right?
Like whether and when he's having sex
and a baby's conceived versus when he's
having sex and nothing, it's just
fun. There's no difference to him.
He doesn't feel a difference.
Whereas a woman, literally,
her body will fucking grow a person,
that person with a brain
that she's serious.
She's sharing things with this
things kicking inside of her.
Like that experience. It'll
fuck you up for a man. I mean,
I would like, I do not like if
there was an a way that you could,
uh,
record what it's like to be someone and
then they give you like a little chip
and you would slip it in there
and I could, I could see you like,
you would allow people, all of your
feelings, the way your skin feels,
the way your emotions are, the
way your psychology is set up.
You would allow all people to literally
be you for a couple of days and the chip
would do the, yeah.
This chip would just sit in your head
and you as food be that person. Yeah,
I would, I would like to feel what
it's like to be pregnant. Really? Yeah.
You want to feel that, that like,
that rip that pay or just like,
just not the birth partner. Fuck
that. And I don't want the debt.
Right. I don't want to get fucked
up. I don't want to get fucked.
I don't want to imagine if that was
the only way you could feel it. Right.
I would,
I would wonder what it would like
to first of all be a maternal woman.
I W I mean I'm really curious as to
what the, the hormones feel like,
what it must feel like. Cause
I don't think we, you know,
when you see a woman you try
to understand like what is,
what's the world through
her eyes, you know,
you're never going to
feel the way she feels.
I'm never gonna look at
somebody else and be like, oh,
they can kill me right now at the
time. You know what I mean too. Yeah.
That too. That's a huge part.
But I mean even just interfacing with
the world through a different type of
human body,
a female human body versus a male human
body in terms of like estrogen and the
testosterone ratio and how your maternal
instincts and oxytocin and all these
different videos, heightened
sensitivity, you know,
in certain situations they have like super
powers that actually describe it that
way. Making humans, humans and their body,
and they have to like make sure that
everyone's safe around them because, uh,
every now and then men will murder
them or yeah. Or rape. Exactly.
Jesus. Crazy. Sorry ladies. Sorry.
Yeah. When you really think about it,
it's like what am a mad
relationship? It's mad.
The relationship between males
and females. Yeah, it's mad.
That's why I always laugh
at dudes who get, you know,
when guys get jack for their divorce
money, I was like, ah, come on.
You're going to be all right.
You got to all the terrible things
that could go wrong. That's just,
you just get jacked for some money.
I liked that perspective actually.
I kind of puts it all in
perspective. You're just like, yeah,
that's how many raped and killed
you killed. He just, he got, look,
people get into bad relationships. I mean,
I'm not happy that someone ever
gets into a bad relationship,
but if you get an a bad
relationship and it's,
she's just a gold digger and
each one would go, oh God.
Like I've had so many friends that
have been like, ah, my fucking ex-wife.
She wants more money. You got to
go to court. I'm like, wow. Yeah,
but you can't get your murder
player. And it's like you fucked up.
You shouldn't have married her.
That's not me. She didn't know.
She didn't know when she was crazy.
Would you read the rape, the murder
preempt? Really? Yeah, for sure.
You sure don't want either one?
Obviously if a guy rapes me and I'm
still alive, then I get to murder him.
Oh Shit. You got to think about it
that way you can get the murder.
I'd rather gone. No, I don't get, I don't
get murdered. I just get raped. Okay.
I'll wait. But then it's like there's
the trauma with that though. You know,
there'll be trauma. You're not gonna
enjoy it. Yeah. It's going to be terrible.
Yeah. But um, it's better
than being dead. Okay.
I'm not saying it's good. No, but,
alright. But for me, he as a man,
as a human, I get raped then
murdered for sure. There you go.
Joe Wick. After that. 100% yeah.
Just so everybody fucking 100% fill
rate me or I'll murder you. Yeah,
I'll have a new goal in life.
But you gotta say goodbye to
everybody before you do it.
Cause you your doctor that you're going
to stay alive. Yeah. It's not John Wick.
John Wick just drives home. Yeah.
They arrest you for dude, fuck you.
And then you kill them and they
go to you immediately. I go, hey,
did you kill it? Like how the fuck do you
mean by the way? No. What happened?
I mean, what does the cop say? It's
just like, dude, he raped me though.
He's just like, ah, yeah, well the,
you can that there's law, you can't,
or a guy because he raped you. O J
says there are rules so you can't,
you can't be saying to the world, Hey,
if you can a shirt, hey Twitter shirts,
I wonder if like he would sue you. Right?
Because like there's people that um,
if you made a shirt,
like if you might say if you made
a Conor McGregor shirt and you, uh,
had some quotes on it,
you were selling it,
he could like maybe sue you if you keep
his face off or he come to your house
with like a bunch of dudes like
take all his stuff back yourself.
A picture of ojs face like leanings.
That selfie camera just says
hurry Twitter world. I mean,
come on Twitter verse by the
way, cause I know it's, oh,
Jay's world. Hey Twitter world. He
can do whatever the fuck you want.
So he did that shirt would be giant.
It's probably being made right now.
There's nerds that are listening
to us right now that are gone.
They're just going to hit pause
right now and make Twitter. Yeah,
you just made a OJ submerge hate
Twitter world. I was just going to wait.
Not going to get that money. The money
I was going to go to the abused women,
good. And waiters,
waiters who've been
murdered by boyfriends.
God Damn little that knife to ugh
personal. And they never found that knife.
They never found that knife.
Yeah. Who had that knife?
I mean Damn OJ Damn Ojai he looked
for is like 17 like an ex-convict.
He looks good. Was playing golf all
day, was he? That's all he does.
Even like golf goes out and
plays golf. He looks great.
He seems to have at least a slight
struggle with communicating right and
walking. He seems like he's gotten
a little slowness towards voice.
We're just fortunate.
You know what I mean?
Which is probably CTE. Oh, is that CT?
But he sounds pretty cool. Pretty
clear, pretty clear. There's a,
there's a hint, there's a
hitch, you know, you get it,
you see it in fighters or um,
just there's a s you never know because
it might just be you're tired. Right.
I'm thinking he's, he's this,
but there's some days where I'm jet
lagged or tired. I'm just really stupid.
I don't talk that good.
He also like, you know,
he did beat two murder cases
that'll make you a little, you know,
he's in his seventies right, isn't
he? Yeah, he's in a seventies yet,
but still there's tourism
is a struggle. Crutch,
slight struggle to the way he's talking.
That makes me think he's dealing
with some sparks. OJ Simpson worried
he has CTE. I have days that
I can't find words. Yeah,
100% but CTE makes you murder people
write that shit. I mean, he could be,
I mean, is that, would that,
would you use that today? Oh, Jay,
that's what his lawyer said. Not really.
One of his lawyers had said that it
had OJ Simpson was a lawyer or was it a
medical advisor? May medical advise.
I said I would bet my medical
license that he had a CT. Yeah.
But he was also saying that it would
have been a part of the defense. Right.
It would have been a part of the,
the crime had happened today. I mean,
that's what I'm saying. Right.
That's why. But Aaron Hernandez,
they were saying [inaudible]
dude with all of them, NDP when,
and obviously you're in a
super violent sport too,
the most violent and
then two, you're gonna,
you're gonna have a high capacity
for violence, right? Yeah. You know,
I mean that does. And then on top of
that, if you're, you're fucking wirings
if you've been smashed so many times
and they do get smashed and their wiring
does go for some of them fighters
and yeah, they get a little haywire.
Chris, Ben Wa. Yeah, that
was terrible. That guy,
that kind of shit is so petrifying. I
could kill his family. I mean, and um,
many people that have experienced extreme
CTE have wound up when they committed
suicide, donating their brain,
like saying, um, you know,
like that one dot. Do Junior, junior sal,
he shot himself in the chest. Right.
So that they could look as brain.
That's hard, man. That's hard. I mean,
that's what fights have you been in
every, tells you you've been concussed?
I don't know. I don't know how
many times I've been concussed. Um,
I've never been knocked unconscious,
but I got TKO in a kickboxing match.
The last fight I ever had, I got
cracked a crack with a left hook.
It was like, it was one of the weirdest
times have ever been hit because um,
I had been a def,
been hit hard before but it never
been hit where my leg stopped working.
They just stopped. They just
stopped. Like he hit me,
he caught me like right at the tip of my
jaw with like a left hook that I didn't
see coming and my leg just went wait
seas, they just gave out. They gave out.
Like they shut off.
There's a nerve in here.
You're saying that's Kinda like you get
hit and your jaw goes sideways and your
head twists and your brain sloshes
around in there and it's like a bolt of
electricity. It's like, it's
like everything shuts off,
shuts off. Um, but I was still
conscious but I was like, oh shit,
what is going on here? Like this is
crazy. And I was like, all right,
get back up two feet. So
the referee was counting,
he got to eight or something
like that. I got up to my feet,
they dusted my gloves off and the kid
came at me again and hit me with an
uppercut, another punch, drop me
again. Then they stopped a fight.
So I was never unconscious,
but that was the worst I'd ever been
like beaten in a fight where it just
knuckle sandwiches at the sparks flying,
which that was what the
last time ever fought.
But other than that there was a lot of
like training sessions where you get
kicked in the face or punched
or there's a lot of those.
It's just just happens
and most of the time,
you know if you get hit full blast, it's
an accident. Can you get tested for CT?
Is that a thing? They test?
There's no test for CT.
They have tested a few
people while they're alive.
They have them look at the
brain to find the stuff.
So they have to drill a hole in your
brain yet to prove to like have on on
denials. You gotta die first. Yeah, the,
they like to do autopsies on people
with CTE and the crazy atrophied brains.
The brain of an 85 year old person
with, with Alzheimer's disease.
It's really nuts man. Like
their brains are fucked up.
There's all these weird proteins
get developed from the concussions
fuck. But like with like, like
calcifies the brain or something.
He does horrible things. He eats
way different parts of the brain.
There's like these little
dark spots and holes. Man.
I'm not exactly sure what the
mental processes but the uh,
the medical processes rather,
but they, it was like dead spots,
like your brains dead days when
they always disgrace. Okay.
Former NFL player confirmed his first
diagnose of CTE in living patient. Yeah.
We had talked about this before.
So they're able now to get, uh,
some sort of an accurate recording of
what your brain looks like and they can
see the CTE without having to open you up.
But I think most of the time it's when
a person's already dead. Maybe their,
their detection methods are
getting better. Listen, man,
if you look at that brain,
go back to that reel,
that image when the guy's
a punk poking at the brain.
Then he's looking at the
x-rays or the, the MRIs.
Look at, look at this, look at
that. Just look at that thing.
That which is protected by a thin layer
of bone is where all of your fucking
thinking takes place. All of it.
It's an Oregon and you
get punched in the face.
All of that is just bro, like
detaching from the walls,
all the connective tissue.
What is that stuff called that?
That real weird stuff that sits between
what kind of connective tissues that
described as between the brain and the
skull. It's like a specific name for it.
Oh, like that? Uh, that, that then
later, yeah, and that stuff gets ripped.
It's tears free and you're, you're,
you're fucked when you get hit,
you're saying. Yeah. Sometimes people
develop internal bleeding after fights.
Like shades is the, yeah, combat sports.
Crazy. I mean it's your, it's your,
oh wait, wait. Another guy just
died, right? Another boxer,
another box or two boxers died in
a very short period of time. Yeah.
Some people think that they should
shorten fights now [inaudible] that they
should make them like eight rounds,
but cause guys are just bigger
and faster and stronger.
I mean the just people just
want to mitigate the, the
thing, the damage, right,
mitigate the damage. But
if you did that in the
high land level fights,
you'd miss amazing fights like
Deontay wilder and Tyson fury.
If that wasn't 12 rounds when when wilder
knocked him down the 12th round and
fewer he rose from the dead,
we would have missed one of the greatest
moments in the history of the sport.
I mean that was an amazing
moment, man. For two reasons. One,
can you see how fucking hard
Deontay punches and two,
that wilder who looked like he was dead
to the world rises up and then outboxes
him for the rest of the round survives,
survives wilder chasing them down and
then outboxes him and then even tags
wilder as wilder to covering up.
That whole round doesn't take place if
you only fight it round because it will
be a test of endurance too. Right. Not
just strength and power for sure. Yeah.
I mean maybe if people were only fighting
eight rounds it would be worse because
they would, they would go harder.
Exactly. That's what I'm saying. Yeah.
And there'd be worse fights cause you
exert all your energy in the first three,
four, three, five rounds.
The only argument against
that though is kickboxing.
Cause in kickboxing they've always
had less rounds. Like um, kickboxing,
Muay Thai fine.
Like a lot of times they'll fight three
rounds or they'll fight five rounds.
I never, I mean come on. I mean
cause it's that, that's yeah,
that like that's fine saying,
I mean you're talking about tree trunks
hitting somebody. You know what I mean?
So awful. That should only
be three to five rounds.
That's never gotten a Charlie horse
like a really bad truck. Yeah.
I want to like recently where like
my whole leg stopped and I was like,
this is possible. I didn't know as
possible. Your whole lake and stuff,
just from a Charlie horse.
There's, there's levels to it.
But the worst I ever saw was chosen.
Aldo fought Uriah faber and uh,
Josie Aldo was one of the most vicious
leg kickers in the history of the sport.
God has led. Kicks were insane. Well,
years this, I hadn't seen this fight.
2012 maybe someone's like, what a favors.
Like what? Like vice before he like,
he's like he's becoming big
at that point. 2012. Yes.
And was fighting for the title. It was
for the featherweight title, I believe,
or the WEC title boy. I feel like that
was like, okay, this is what it was.
If I'm correct, I think it was,
I think I'm incorrect. Yeah.
Is that a, is that in the WC? Yes, it is.
So I think what this was was the
UFC and the WC had a paper view,
but it was just, they didn't,
it wasn't quite the UFC yet,
so I don't think they called it anything.
I think they just called it
all though versus favor and uh,
the UFC promoted it.
I think that was how they got
around something we tried to do.
Dude that is all doe in its prime sun.
That is that combination right there.
It's called the Dutchy where they throw
a left hook to the body and the right
leg kick. But this just showed you how
God damn tough. You're right. Favorites.
The impressive performance for
sure off offensively. I mean,
although it was in his
full prime, it was amazing.
But what's really impressive is
how Uriah faber was able to endure.
I mean it was how many
rounds does this go?
It went the full distance
full five rounds. What's
that? Yeah. Then you see his legs
after fucking crazy man. Yeah.
When did they start doing um, five
round main events for the UFC?
That was an early, or they, I
don't think they grew to that.
I feel like I'm remembering it's, it's
been this way for quite a while. So it's,
it's hard to remember the exact year,
but they, they didn't use to 2011, 2011.
Oh, so this is like this decade 11.
That's when they started going
to five rounds from main events.
UFC Dana White says all UFC made
events to become five rounds. Right.
But before that championship
fights were championship fights,
always five rounds. Trying to go
back to the early, early days.
At this point,
five round fights have been contested
or contests have been reserved for title
fights all. Yeah, that's what I had said.
But w when did they make them
five rounds for title fights?
Know when did they decide that a title
fights five rounds and a regular fight?
Three rounds. Well it was that wonder
if that was from the beginning.
Cause you gotta remember in the
beginning days they didn't even have time
limits. Really? No.
Well it was just you go into
like somebody's got a lot
of fights where there was
no time limits. They were terrible.
And you just fought until like somebody
tapped up. Yeah, I looked that up. Look,
especially in Japan,
like hoist Gracie had a fight with
Sakuraba that went like 90 minutes. Damn.
Yeah. Why? Well in Japan they,
they didn't, they had a,
a different way of
looking at these contests.
They would make crazy matchups where
there was a, you can't win by, um,
decision. You could only win by knockout.
They would like cro cop who was
like one of the greatest, um,
strikers in MMA ever because he came
from k one kickboxing and he was big and
Katelyn kickbox and then
made his way over to um,
to Japan and started fighting and
pride. And the first time he fought,
he fought Vandelay Silva. It
was like a big [inaudible],
but they had a special rules match
and the special rules was, um,
if it went to a decision, it
was a draw no matter what.
If no one got knocked out,
it was a draw. And um,
if they fought on the ground, it
can only be for like 15 seconds.
It's like some crazy rule.
It was basically just boxing
and order does kickboxing,
I forget what the amount of time was,
but there was a limited amount of time
where they could fight on the ground.
Yeah. So I think that must have
been better for us. That's crazy.
Cro Cop had the balls to step into MMA,
like really with very
little real MMA training.
It was mostly just as a kickboxer.
But then he started as
his career got further,
he got better and better at stuff and
takedowns but so Japan would do that.
They would make like they would make
fights where one guy, where's a g,
the other guy doesn't, they
would make fights with,
they made fights with Bob Sapp who
was like 370 pounds against the guys.
200 pounds. [inaudible] the guy
smashes him. That's a smash.
They made a bunch of
like horrible mismatches.
They'd make mis like they'd make
Vandelay Silva fight someone who was just
deathly scared of him that was going to
get palms to the ground and they did it
just to watch. So you could watch
Vandelay smash somebody. Yeah,
they sound like circus messages.
They had crazy fights, man.
They had crazy fights. And you
went over there with the call?
The fights or just the watch? You'll
know. I only watched him here.
I've never been in Japan to
watch fights other than the UFC.
We did a UFC out there at once.
Yeah, that was fun. They're really,
really polite. Yeah. In between, like,
like while the actions happening,
they're sitting there quiet and polite.
Like you don't hear a lot
of like screaming and crazy.
I didn't know that. Yeah.
And then they get, they,
they're, they're very, uh,
they applaud like when things
happen, cause I know it's broadcast.
It's interesting. Yeah. It's gotta be
bad. It's not bad, but it is different.
Yeah. But like I'm like, I was like Tyson
and Buster Douglas like was that loud?
I wonder. I wonder. I don't, I don't
remember like all those fights over there.
Yeah. You're saying like the quiet, I
mean that would, that seems like it sucks.
But early on, early on they
were super knowledgeable.
Like early on in mixed martial arts.
Like if you watch fights or in Japan,
if somebody passed guard, everybody
would cheer. It's a little, yeah,
it's like a smart audience. Yeah. They
know exactly what's going on there.
They're well educated in
someone gets them out,
they start clapping and like
this a, it's just a different,
completely different kind of a reaction
for the audience. Political change.
It's cool though. It's like when
you watch the UFC events from Japan,
it's changing.
They're becoming a little bit more used
to like being rowdy and having a good
time. But in the old days you could
hear the corners crystal clear.
So the quantity the to press down with
the butterfly down with the butterfly.
Look out for the right arm. We have the
right arm. Okay, keep that over. Hook.
Keep that over hook. And you would hear
that like, but he could hear it too.
Everybody could hear it. So the,
the guy who you're fighting is hearing
the advice against the shit crystal clear
cause there's, there's no noise.
I mean that must make fights.
I mean like, yeah, just long and boring
cause they all know like your strategy.
No, no, no, no. Crazy, crazy.
Just to get someone knows that you're
trying to get their arm doesn't mean
you're not going to get their arm.
It's still crazy. It's still crazy.
But it's um,
it was really interesting because you
could hear everything you hear yelling
out. There's nothing like Vegas. Yeah.
Vegas just like anybody screaming. Yeah.
Well, you know what's, I find the,
sometimes the most enthusiastic crowds
are the ones that don't get the UFC there
very often. So when it does get
there, they get fucking super pumped.
I can't believe it's their
live, you know, like where,
uh,
I mean there's a lot of cities where
we've gone to were like all Texas always
says wild ass. I mean, that makes sense.
Yeah. That's a good place for USC.
But there's a lot of cities that just
don't get it all the time. Chicago,
whenever we were in Chicago, it's
big. You've never been to Chicago.
There's been, oh, we go, yeah, we're in
Chicago. I go to Chicago all the time.
It's a big drink and towns though.
Fuck yeah, like I feel like, yeah,
any like biters had a big drinking town,
there's going to be like this isn't,
yeah, it doesn't matter what it is. Yeah.
So when we were talking about
reparations earlier like that,
I don't think they should give money
to people like individual money.
That's what I'm saying. But what I think
they should do is definitely put money.
Like if you, if you were
a guy who was the manager
of a city, let's look at that. Let's
look at the city like a city was a store.
Okay. And you're the manager
of the store and, but the,
the section over near the
cleaning products, it's,
everything explodes all the
time and it's fucking dangerous.
And mops are fallen and you're
like, well, we got, you know,
several things in order. City's good
revenue looks good. Like, wait, wait babe,
babe, buddy. What the fuck are you
talking about? You're the manager.
What are you doing about this? Look at
this spot. He was like, what? Oh no,
that's a, the cleaning products. I mean,
I don't know what to do about the
cleaning products. They explode.
The mops fall off the racks.
I just waved my hands at it.
You would never tolerate that. No.
But a mayor like that, Pete Buddha,
judge, a good judge guy. Yeah.
He could have all sorts of chaos going
on in his town while he's out there
campaigning for president. Right?
Yeah. Nobody cares. Nobody cares.
You don't have to fix it. You don't
have to fix it. Yeah. But I'd be like,
well how do you feel like I'm what I'm
saying it's an infrastructure problem.
So how do you fix it?
So you're saying take what 15% or whatever
percentage from like all these big
corporations and they're like, they
should be paying even saying that. Right.
I'm boot up a little. What I was saying
though, if there was a direct line,
I mean I don't know if you can do
this anymore at this point in time,
but if there was a direct way you could
show this is the amount of money that
came from slavery and they still have,
I mean how are you finding
that out though? I don't
know. Yeah, there's no way,
because by the way, we can't
even trace like, you know what,
I don't know what tree plantation I
was even at, you know what I mean?
Where my family lineage is. Well there
was a bunch of Nazi money that they cha,
they traced, they've traced Nazi
money. They've definitely done that.
They've definitely done that
with a little more modern though.
I mean say from 16 or
15 or 14 till you know,
1860 something. Yeah. We're dealing
with like an 80 year gap. Yeah,
it'd be hard.
But if there was like some clearly
established business that used to be a
plantation. Right. You
know, I'm also, you know,
Jewish people can't y'all keep
things into account so like you can,
you can trace that money. Like there
was no, here's an unpopular thought,
this is, this is what I think.
I think we should probably consider doing
that with definitely areas that were
impacted by slavery.
But then also areas that have been
impacted by economic crisis too.
Like not just the areas impacted by
like we have to fix the bad spots in the
country. All told like full stop.
Like we kinda fixed those people that
live in West Virginia. In the mountains.
Yeah. The fucking pill. People.
Any, any Troy community. Yeah.
Any poor community. Yeah.
But first like as a general
acknowledgement of like
what this country was
founded on, you've got to fix the
areas that were fucked up by slavery.
The idea that you shouldn't, it's
like, aren't we on a team together?
Okay. Aren't we team America? Right. Well,
team America would want all of its
members to be in good shape, good state.
We want less losers. Yeah. Right.
Here's the way you get less losers.
You provide more opportunity and you
fix the spots that are fucked up.
And there's no, that comes with
education though, Joe. I mean,
you're talking about,
I mean, there'll be, the illiteracy
rate is crazy down there.
So you're saying the idiots, you know
what I mean? But it's like, no, no, no.
Yeah, they're idiots. What I'm saying
is they're stuck your horrible place.
Right. You're an idiot if you
don't want to fix that. No,
that's what I get that I think
it's just unpopular. Like no,
like here's what everybody wants to hear.
We want to go to out of Afghanistan
and I don't know. Right.
We want to provide free
healthcare for everyone. Yeah.
We think that education
should be free. Ah,
I'm going to give you
$1,000 a month. Yeah.
But no one's saying art, our whole thing.
If we looked at it as an
ecosystem, there's disease spots,
there's spots where it's not going
well, it's sick, it's not doing well.
There's too much crime,
there's too much pollution,
there's too much environmental
factors, whatever the,
whatever the factors are taken
advantage of communities delivers those,
whether it's environmental factors
like the water in Flint, Michigan,
or whether it is a crime,
Britain's streets of Baltimore or
Philly or wherever, wherever it is,
where it's bad, we'll
find spots where it's bad.
Those spots have to be
addressed, like you don't,
just to address it with law enforcement,
you got to figure out a plan to
slowly reinvigorate those spots.
We have. There's no severe,
pretty laughing. I like what
you were saying earlier,
even about the Italian cities, how they
do have the mamma pop thing, you know,
we keep the money in the community,
right? They haven't sold out to the,
to the corporations who are just
like draining those, those, you know,
those communities. Right. But the thing
is, it's like, it's so tourism based,
the kind of don't have to
because it's like this.
The places where I'm going to it.
Like, uh, I went to the mall fee coast,
which is like really popular for
tourism and uh, you know, you go,
you go to these places,
there's no incentive cause
there's people there all the time.
But I'm saying like,
there's no incentive to give
into corporation instead of like,
my parents had to having to go to Cosco.
Maybe there's like a hardware store
down the street that you know,
has like I'm trying to go to
Pete's cause he's got, you know,
he's got camera's over here. So you
keep the money in the community.
Like I think we're like local grocers,
that kind of thing. You know, like,
Oh hey, I'm not going to go to a bond
or a routes. I'm just going to go to,
you know, Edna's cause she's got,
you know, the cabbages I like. Yeah,
but what if you don't have that,
then the only thing you
got is target or Walgreens.
Like he's got to deal with what I'm
saying. But that's, that's, you know,
that's there. That's the,
those poor communities.
I'm saying like they're putting those
there and they're just draining.
Those people have just like, you know,
maybe getting opportunities that,
you know, they, they, they,
they can thrive in like Italian
communities you're saying? Yeah. It's,
they also make it financially
almost impossible to compete.
Like you can't sell things as cheap as
they can. Right. They get better deals.
Like if you have a mom and pop shop and
you're selling like shovels or stuff
like that almost is home depot. Home
Depot is, we made these ourselves.
I don't give a fuck.
Those shuffles would be like $5 less
and that's all anybody cares about that.
That's a problem. All right, well then
how do you build infrastructure then?
I mean, I'm saying incentivize parents
because like that's gonna like, you know,
help those guys. Like maybe, you know,
it's got the whole family figure out what
do we need to do about junior here or
you know,
a little little lady here and like
figure out how we're going to make them
better members of society.
I like that idea. Yeah.
I mean, I think that if,
if we could figure out how much they
would get and where the money would come
from and if it did work,
it would be insane. Yeah.
I mean you think about how much money
you have to spend on the criminal justice
system on healthcare system from assaults
and all sorts of things when when
people go bad. Yeah.
And what would you say save if buy ins
through incentivizing education and
making sure that people get compensated
financially for, for education success.
And then all of a sudden it starts
booming and then you have way less crime.
That would be amazing. I'm
saying Bro, I mean that,
that almost feels like it's
a no brainer, you know?
I mean you're talking about
infrastructure, that's
infrastructure. Hey Dude,
bunch run for president. Any other awesome
ideas? Cause that's an awesome idea.
I gotta look, I'm an
obviously a financial moron.
I don't know if that would
actually how much that would cost,
but if it could be done, how much
preparations? More cost. I mean,
like I hear it keeps,
you know, and they keep,
they keep saying we need to have it,
but it's like, what does that mean?
Is there an, is that an infrastructure
thing or are we just giving people money?
Isn't that a weird one? Because it
keeps coming up. Yeah. It's like,
it comes up and then it goes away
and it's like, hey, you know,
we never fucking sorted this
out. I mean, I'll tell you this.
I remember on a guy that was bully
hunter, he put on Twitter, he put,
it's been [inaudible]. He said, white
people, if you wanna give me reparations,
my bin Mo's open. And he made like, I
don't know, like 100 bucks. And then a,
we went on the road and then, yeah,
we all, he bought us a skittles,
beautiful ice tea and Hennessy
reparation money. That's just like,
you can't do that with the community man.
Do you ever see where an m hotep Jesus
walked into Starbucks? Oh Jeez, man.
And his a reparation coffee nine.
He saw the interesting character.
I've had him on my
podcast, but he, um, he,
there was a Starbucks had got busted
for telling these young black guys that
they had to leave. Um,
and it became a big deal where they
developed a new policy where they're never
going to just tell people to leave.
And so the problem with
that was they'd be like,
well what about homeless people?
Now you've got homeless people that have
liked to hang around Starbucks and the
policy is they can't even tell them to
leave, but she's like, all these days,
and I go, this black people in
homeless people now Starbucks,
this story was really a,
it was big in the news that Starbucks
was racist and that they had kicked.
So Starbucks was like
apologizing publicly.
So while that was going on in hotep Jesus,
like I'm going to go get some free coffee,
went into coffee and he goes
out here, I'm a, I have a,
I get my reparations coffee.
I'm here to get coffee for free.
Cause I heard y'all were racist. And
so the lady's like, yeah, I heard that.
And she could pour him a cup of
coffee. She gives them a cup of coffee.
I heard the love though.
She heard that there was something
racist going so she had a free coffee to,
it's hilarious shit. Hotep Jesus.
It's hilarious. But it's um, you know,
Starbucks eat like anybody can go in
there now. Yeah. But it's all, you know,
whatever coffee. You
still your big coffee guy.
I'm not a big guy with number two.
I'm a black tea guy. Dude of coffee.
We got a new coffee from Onnit called
Fuck Yak coffee. I'm scared to try.
Apparently
it's a w did you see it? Did you see
the bag? I have some. I've tried it.
It's fucking ridiculous. I mean, but
it's got caffeine crystals in it. Yeah.
I was trying to, I didn't
know what that meant,
but how much caffeine
does it have? I couldn't,
I just made a French press of it,
so I couldn't tell you off the wall.
I don't even think, I think just like,
we don't think caffeine
affects me like normal people.
Does it actually take to Jamie's
robot? Jamie takes edibles.
They don't do a damn thing. Oh
my God. I tried to Trey. Yeah.
Do not get into an editable
eating contest with Jamie. Yo,
that's $1 million idea. He's a
rateable, you'll kill people. He'll,
he's a robot. He just throws him down.
They don't do a goddamn thing to him.
Yeah. One, one out of 20 times.
Maybe a small effect, but yeah. Yeah.
But like a small effect
for like 500 milligrams.
He's got really good chicken
thousand. I took a thousand. Yeah,
I'd play some video games and four
hours later I was like, all right,
I'm a little tired. I want
it. I'll stop. You got, yeah.
You got like that gene though.
He was like a gene that
actually let's go back to HIV.
There was a gene that some like people
have like you can't get it. Yes.
There's some people that with your edibles
here movie about that where like they
use a guy to, cause he's got the one
g oh, what is that God damn movie?
I feel like I've seen it recently.
Oh, I did. Okay. Here's what it is.
Um,
it's called the man who shot Hitler and
then big foot and I saw it recently.
It's a Sam Elliot movie.
Whoa. Okay. It actually, wow.
It is an interesting movie and he
can't get it strictly. I enjoyed it.
I watched it on a flight and I downloaded
it cause I was like, what is this?
What is the man who shot
Hitler? And then big foot,
but I'm a big Sam Elliot Fan and
it got [inaudible]. So, uh, I said,
okay, I'll give it a shot.
It's really interesting.
I mean he, I mean it's,
they're not hiding it.
He shot big foot and then Hitler, the
man who killed Hitler and then bigfoot.
When did those come out? I don't
know. And he can't get HIV.
Last year the thing was that
he had a very specific gene.
They brought him back to service
because after he'd killed Hitler,
he's an older man,
but he had a very specific gene that
made him immune to this disease that big
foot had and that big foot was sick
and that his virus was killing all the
wildlife that was anywhere near him.
And there was a dead zone around big when
they were tracking him and they had to
have someone go in
there and kill big foot.
So they bring in Sam Elliot
when he's like 70 years old.
Spoiler alert to go and kill bigfoot.
It's fucking cool. I enjoyed it man.
I mean it's not, it's not, you
know, 2001 a space odyssey,
but it's fucking cool moving. It's a
definitely a B movie. I mean, damn,
I didn't get, is that bigfoot
where this little shadow thing? No,
they see I'm pretty up close. I mean
maybe they don't show it in the preview,
but it's pretty up close. It's gnarly.
I don't want to say too much. Yeah,
don't completely say too much.
But he does kill Hitler. Yeah. Well
killed Hitler and then, and then big foot.
It says it in the title. People
really want to kill Hitler.
That's like a thing that movies are
doing, Huh? Yeah, yeah. You know,
I was watching a video of a Hitler
tweaking Hitler's on speed. You know,
he did a lot of speed.
He's got the 1936 Olympics and he's
sitting in the audience like this,
like tweet. I was like an actual
like footage of the actual footage.
Apparently somebody had taken it
and sped it up and uh, it made it,
uh, unrealistic just to show, like
make it look for these really, really,
really tweaking. And then, um,
it was hard to find for some people
to find the actual speed footage.
But this is, this is the actual
speed footage they believe.
Um, so he's just rocking
back and forth tweaking.
Wow. He does have crack head energy.
That's amazing. Good percent tweaking.
So I mean there's no way you rock like
that for next weekend. He's like 52.
Where's his left hand?
What is happening there?
He touches his left hand's got a glove
and he's rubbing a gun on his deck.
Go back to the, I'm gonna say that again.
Please replay. Please look at this.
How weird is that man? How weird is
it to see that guy go full screen?
So he jerks off with his
gun. He masturbates in a way.
He's literally just joking about a
gun. I don't think it's really gone,
but he's definitely got
his hand on his deck.
He's like a a guy who's freaking out.
It might mean, might as
well be a meth head. Right.
And you see how they let this
guy like, I mean look at him.
Something he's touching his
dick with so yet. Yeah, exactly.
There's some stuff. It looks
like more hands curled over.
It doesn't like he's got
something in his hand, Dude.
He's rubbing something on his
pecker. Do you have a cane? Oh,
he's running this cat. Oh
yeah, maybe. Is that it?
He's like look, go,
go towards the end of it and we'll pause
when you can see the hand right next to
his dick. So weird that
is moving now watch,
watch. When you see his hand,
get that bar out of the bottom.
There it is over the pants hand job
that he's giving himself. Look good.
He's got something in his hand and that's
something in his hand is in between
his legs. You said Kane, I mean you might
be right. You said, I mean you were,
you were joking about the gun, but I
mean it could be, it could be a cane,
it could be a Ruger, it might be a gun.
I think it looks more like cane now
that I'm looking at it. But either way.
Yeah, he's definitely rubbing as
the guy. He's, if Trump was on TV,
just tweaking, tweaking hard.
Oh Fuck China. Fuck these
fucking trade relations.
Fuck Jeff for your Epstein. Fuck all
these assholes tweaking. Just tweaking.
Could you imagine doesn't
he knows Jeff, right?
Jeff Epstein apparently knew him,
but apparently they had a falling out
over our mantra and I was reading a story
about it over a male, like
when he sold him or no,
they were both trying to buy some super
exclusive property that was like the
crown jewel. Palm Beach.
It was this a six acre mansion that
overlooks the ocean on the beach.
It's beautiful. And it's apparel have a
plantation for girls. Well these, yeah.
Well it's also one of those things
where like if you're in a part of these
communities,
there are certain properties that are
iconic and to own them it would elevate
your social status. Like did you
hear Trump bought the mansion?
[inaudible] so like Felicia
had like a name to it.
The places off the charts. If you,
you see it on TV, like you
get a a sense, what is this
county known to having
a famous walking stick.
[inaudible] I thought you were
showing Epstein and Trump. He did.
He did have the cane. Um,
what was the house? Google.
The, the House that they competed about.
Trump and him competed over a
house like maybe waterfalls. Well,
it's really old. I think
14 year olds in every room.
It's like if someone was like
a super billionaire character,
and I dunno, think of me, name some
famous man like the Hearst castle,
Hearst castle for sale. They'd
all be trying to get it.
Trump and Epstein's friendship reportedly
soured after they fought over a $41
million palm beach mansion two
weeks after the homes auction.
Cops received a tip about underage
women in Epstein's house. Oh Shit.
That was [inaudible].
Let's see if they have pictures of
the place and that's a Taj Mahal.
Look at that thing. Yeah, that's
it. Yeah. Thanks gorgeous dude.
It's dope as fuck. The, the images
are insane. That's it right there.
Click on that. Look at that
place so that you get it.
They're fighting over who's got
the biggest dick on this beach?
If you own that motherfucker, you bought
that place. Like you're king baller.
Everybody wants to have the party
at your house. Right? I mean,
so I guess there's just a few of these
type of mansions down in Palm Beach,
but there's a lot of them.
I mean there's, you know,
I don't know what the
number is, but there's a,
a good solid number of them
competing against each other.
That's fucking incredible. It's sort of
like, um, like the White House. Well,
it's sorta like those houses in Malibu,
like there's some houses in
Malibu when you look at like,
there's one crazy mansion overlooking
the sea and then another one next to it.
Like the those I know live
in this neighborhood. I
don't live there either, man.
Oh Shit. They've burnt
mostly burnt to a crisp.
It did point to Mary
crazy fly over it now.
It's was like just so many
houses chart on just chart. Yeah,
but there was houses where the people
do live with that kind of a view.
I mean that's, those are
super, super valuable.
And in Florida and West Palm Beach,
apparently looking super, super wealthy.
Yeah. There's $35 million.
I mean a 3 million amazing
Italian renaissance style
mega mansion in Palm Beach,
Florida. If you buy
that, you're king cock.
You're just swinging dick all
over. Come on in. By the way,
why did God make the deal
like the Dick size? Why? Why?
Why is that make you work harder? Really?
That's really the reason that if
you just, if you had a giant hog,
you'd be just waiting around waiting for
girls to come to you and saying, well,
he could have made Dick's all the same
size and then there'd be no competition.
No, no, no. Can't make years the
same size either. Sorry, not noses.
Not eyebrows. No formity no eugenics.
Yeah, you got to work harder.
You got a little Dick to figure out
how to get by in this world like a,
you're God's brain and
those big Dick dudes, man,
they just don't have the motivation
to hardly ever get anything done.
It just to, to busy slinging Dick,
that's you skirt around them.
You pass them in the game. Um,
take them on the inside turn.
I didn't know that. That's what it is,
right? Like I said, I believe in God.
Again, it doesn't make sense that there
are sloths. Okay? Why is that fair?
Why is there lies if they fucking hate it?
They fucking hate jack by
eagles. You know it is.
When the main thing that eats
use a bird and you're a mammal,
how often does that happen
if you're not a mouse?
It's not a field mouse in an owl.
That's hilarious. By the way.
I didn't know you that they a,
they already talked shit about
Sloss in the animal kingdom, Bro.
They all talk shit on slots. Slots moves
slow so slow that mold grows on them.
I've seen it's gross. It's
crazy. Is it really there?
That's how lazy they are and
they just can't be any better.
They just move real slow. That's just
what they do. And mold grows on them.
That's gross. Yeah. I was at a wildlife
sanctuary and like Sylmar I think it is.
Take my kids there and they've got a
slap on my God. So cute. And I'm like,
why is this thing moldy? And they're
like, oh, it grows. Like moss grows on it.
Like green fungus, like a
tree. Like, look at that.
Look at all that shit. Oh my God.
Moss growing on them because they're so
god damn slow that plants can grow on
them. I mean, is that healthy? I mean
it looks great by the way. This works.
It's almost like camouflage, but a that
one of the main things that eat them,
uh, in his it mouth is, uh,
this eagle called um, fuck,
what is it called? The
Harpy Eagle thing. Yeah.
It's a giant eagle that lives in South
America that just fucks up slots each
slot. Man, sloths, me and monkeys too.
It eats monkeys too. But look at that.
Carrying a sloth to him. I
mean, well yeah, that's a,
that's not the big slough though. No,
but it's a big fuck. It's the barrier.
Yeah. I mean look at those thighs.
Yeah Dude. That thing is all power.
All the power. And that's the, I
think that's the biggest eagle. Yeah,
the heartbeat. I think that's
the biggest eagle. I mean, damn,
that's majestic. I mean
those are small slots.
These like baby sloths that eats like
full grown sloths, loss, slow, slow,
anybody, whatever. I mean the staff
can't really defend itself. Oh my God.
He army pushing the armadillos
body. How crazy is that?
How crazy is how he can crush the Armidale
his body with its claws. That's one.
It's got it with one hand. It's
one handing that thing. An arm.
A human arm. Oh right, right
up. Tear your meat apart.
We're so doughy man. Yeah.
We're so likable. So mushy.
It would just tear your arm apart.
Just climbing onto your arm. Like,
that's why those dudes wear those crazy
arm sleeves when they have a falcon on
their own because it was just
cause they were really
easy to slice up. Yeah.
We have no armor fucking
thing with a rabbit. Whoo.
Look at his legs and things. Bad Ass.
It is a beast that doesn't look real.
That one's got a little band on its leg.
It's been captured. So there either.
Is that a carving? No,
that's real. So they,
they leave the oh they leave the the
rabbit there and it swoops in and get the
rabbit. It's hard to see what the fuck
it is. Cause all those watermarks.
So obnoxious with the
watermarks shit. I get it Bro.
What is that thing right there? Is
that a fox is about to eat right here.
Oh yeah it is. Yeah. They eat foxes. Damn.
[inaudible] fighting the foxes fighting
with the eagle over a rabbit there.
They're fighting over flux
fighting over a Fox. The yeah,
the Eagle stealing. Yeah.
Just eat the, eat the fucks.
Eagle Glam grabbed slough from tree.
Oh is that a true oh is that the slaw?
I'm going to see a video of it.
You see a video of the slaw cause
it is kind of fucked up deer bucks.
One thing they do do though is they pull,
they do do you do have to
say do and then do again,
one thing they do as well is they grab
goats and fling them off the side of
cliffs. You ever see that? No,
but that's hilarious. They do.
They just flick them off. They grab
it looks more real, but I don't know.
What do they do? That's real,
bro. That's probably real.
But there's video of it. They do it to
kill them so they can eat them. Okay.
I was gonna say, yeah,
that makes perfect sense.
I was wondering why they're
doing it. They're just assholes.
Just kicking them off though.
That'll be hilarious and perfect.
Well that's what cats do.
You know housecats ever seen the numbers
of how many animals house cats kill per
year? You're kidding. It's in
the billions. You're kidding.
B B billion B heads kill other animals
by way. Watch this. Watch this. Yeah,
we'll, we'll, we'll show that right
after. Uh, we'll have to see. Look,
he's dragging. Oh,
the goat off the cliff and then drops
it to have it smashed against the rocks.
Look at that. Look at that. That is dough.
And then it hits the ground and then the
ego swoops down and starts heating it.
So it's like planning on
throwing this thing off.
It understands the consequences. It
understands that that thing can't fly.
So it's not just grabbing it swooping
down and grabbing it and it broke its
neck. It's throwing it into the rock,
throwing it off the cliff so he can eat
it. And that's brilliant. Fucking crazy.
That's brilliant. What was the other
thing we were just talking about? I said,
oh, the bird. Oh, well the numbers. Okay.
The sheer numbers of birds
that house cats kill.
Just house cats. Just meow out
in the backyard. No, just murder.
Oh, the murder. Murder. Death.
Just jump up and grab birds.
I had this cat, her name was spazz.
She was a fluff ball cat and
she would bring me these birds.
1.4 billion tons,
many 3.7 billion birds in
the continental US each year.
Cats kill from 1.4 billion to
as many as 3.7 billion birds.
Just birds. That's not mice. That's
not squirrels. Just birds. Just birds.
I had a cat when I was growing up and
he killed a squirrel and was a walking
across the street with it in his mouth.
It was one of the weirdest things I've
ever seen the eat or just like just carry
it in his mouth. He just, his
name, we knit. We called him kitty.
We were very unoriginal, were kids.
I had a name for him that was like the
Black Panther in a Conan the barbarian
book, but everybody fucking
hated me. The veto on it.
They never called them and
they just called them kitty.
So we eventually just wound up
calling him kitty. But Anyway,
kid herself park walking across the street
with a squirrel in between his legs.
So he had the squirrel by
the mouth, by its neck,
rather in his mouth and he was walking
with a squirrel underneath them,
just dragging it with it in between his
legs and it was almost as big as him.
That's nuts. I'm looking at this. I'm
like, what a creepy little thing with,
because a squirrels, they're like
plagued. Don't they know? Yeah.
I think it like they, that
squirrel plague. Squirrel
plague black plague. Right.
Wait a minute. No squirrels.
This was like this.
This was like last decade right there.
Even like maybe even this decade.
It's a squirrel plague. Yeah. There's
like a black plague for squirrels. Really?
Yeah, Dude. Well, I know
there was a, um, a co couple,
I think it was a man and a
woman. Right? Here we go. Whoa.
Plague infested squirrel
caused the closure of a
California campground this week
after it was found during your routine
trapping Los Angeles County health
officials confirmed.
Actually don't ever touch dead squirrels
who play [inaudible] play. Holy Shit.
I think there was a, I think that's
what those people got that ate that.
Marmot liver. Ugh.
There was some people that got sick and
died from the plague really recently,
like within the last couple of months
because they had eaten a raw marmot liver.
A marmot is like some kind of a rodent
and they had killed this Marmet and ate
his liver and this is
here in the states. Fuck.
It wasn't Mongolia. I thought
it was an America Mongolian,
it's Mongolian couple died. Right. But
they didn't die doing it in America.
Thank God to make sure that they
didn't come here and get it.
But it says, I thought it,
I thought the story was they died over
here and like they'd come over here and
try to re-enact some sort of
a, um, a ritualistic meal.
Ugh.
Where they eat this raw liver and they
ate this raw liver and got the plague
son. Does it say where it happened?
Okay. Um, yeah, it's like certain
countries in Africa too. There's like a,
you can like eat human right?
Like, like Cannibal, like, uh,
legally [inaudible] I
don't know if it's legal.
I know there was like a story I read
on it or something like that about, uh,
these like places in like Africa you can
like eat him with this ultimate stone
or talk. It really is, sorry about that
place, Bro. I know I read about it,
I'd be read. Well, do you remember the,
I don't know if you ever saw
this vice piece on Liberia.
I think that might've been it then. Yeah.
Vice Guide to travel and Liberia where
they were saying this guy who was his
name was general button naked
and a general button naked.
He had become a preacher later in
life, but when he was young preacher,
but naked. Yeah. When he was young,
he would go to war totally naked
and he would shoot people. Oh,
that was a beast of no nation was it?
Yeah. You see beast of no nation now. OK.
Uh, he just Elba. He plays
like a Idi Amin or a, um, uh,
what's that thing called? Coney, whatever
it was. Anyway, he's got these trials,
soldiers basically, and uh, yeah,
they just go from my tribe to tribe
and just kill it. They're like,
and they just genocide. Just go
bless your tribe. How about them?
Whatever happened with
that, Coney remember that?
I think he still let go like a warlord.
But you remember how it was like this
gigantic movement and it was this big
thing and everybody was talking about it.
And then this one guy in San Diego
that was a part of starting it,
he wound up being naked,
wandering around the street,
masturbating in front of people and
some crazy shit that made him like that.
Not Credible. Then I make that up. He
was doing something along those lines,
right. He basically had a schizophrenia
break or a psychotic break.
I'm not a doctor. Something went
wrong. Something went wrong, dad.
I blew a flick. That's the cat. Yeah,
they called them tripod in that.
But I think you're talking about the
same guy. Like when he went to war,
like as a child soldier.
Yeah, he was butt naked.
The thing is a different
guy because this guy,
his name literally was
general button naked,
but I think there's a bunch of
them that did that. But anyway,
on the Liberia show,
he said that he busted these street cart
guys selling human meat and he said he
knew because he knew what meat tastes
like cause he had eaten it. What the fuck?
He knew that it was human meat. He knew
it wasn't pork. He knew it wasn't beef.
Liberia is crazy by the way.
I mean like are they sell? No,
they have slaves out there for some
imagine the gall of going to the cops and
saying that man is selling human meat.
Well how do you know that kind of walk?
Cause I've eaten it. I mean fuck,
fuck. What'd you eat? Human,
um, I depends on what you have to
do to stay alive. Right, right.
Like where are you? What's app?
Like if you were in that movie alive
when they're scooping the [inaudible]
saying that with broken spoon
Donner pass or something like that.
What are you going to do? But then
the, I'm saying like as a Foodie, like,
you know, you go to like a restaurant
food. That's what I'm saying.
Like if they cook it up nice. You know
what I mean? You get some Tabasco,
you found eating to dude's foot. Ugh,
you've got foot soup or dick soup.
A Dick Burger. Well there was
one guy. Okay. There was another,
there was one guy story,
but there was one guy that I had read
about where online he requested that
someone kill him and eat him.
Damn, that's his death wish. Yeah.
And I think it was in Germany.
Of course they met together,
got together with a guy.
The guy cut his dick off and they
cooked it and uh, they ate it together.
He ate part of his deck and then
the guy wound up killing him and um,
oh wait, wait. So this guy was alive
and they cooked an aids duck. Oh, he,
they ate his Dick Together.
They did. They did it together.
It was so German did, it
was, it was this guy's idea.
He requested it. Okay. I'm like
craigslist or one of those things.
Let's cut my dick off and then an evening
we're going to eat it and then you're
gonna kill me. And again, he wanted
to, he wanted the guy to eat him too.
And again, I think the
guy did eat some of them,
but there was a question as to whether
or not a person is a lot to eat.
How do you, how do you prosecute that?
What do you do? Like if someone said,
I want you to cut my dick off and you
cut their dick off, I want to cook it,
need it, and then you both cook it. Need
it. I want you to kill me and eat me.
Okay. And they got kills them and
eats them like, well, what is that?
It's not a regular murder.
I think I'm reading the same stories
that manslaughter filmed it. Oh,
they filmed it? Yeah. Yeah.
They filmed it of like him cutting
his dick off in the eating it. Yeah.
I think they filmed the whole
murder. What's the threshold? Oh,
so it's like a snuff film. Yeah.
Yeah. But the guy requested it.
Yeah. Pull it up so we
can, uh, we can read it.
This one from 2003. Yeah,
that's a, that's the one. Yeah.
Yup. 45. [inaudible] you've
done from my live body.
Wow.
See? Yeah. He posted a personal
ad saying, seeking well-built man,
18 to 30 years old for slaughter. Whoa.
For slaughter. He wrote,
I offer myself to you and we'll
let you dine from my live body,
not butchery, dining,
whoever really all caps wants to do it.
We'll need a real all caps victim,
all caps, exclamation point.
There's two.
Started swapping increasingly explicit
emails and on March nine 2001 Braden took
a day off work, never to return.
He sold everything he owned,
including his treasured sports car,
wiped his computer hard drive and
bought a one way ticket to castle near
Frankfurt and met him off the train.
They bought painkillers at a chemical
shop while headed back to the house at
first brand has got cold feet
and one to return to Berlin.
Muse said,
but he reconsidered swallowed painkillers
and medication to make him sleepy.
He said, now do it. Muse.
Sit the video camera rolling and went
to work with a kitchen knife. Wow, dude.
We went into the bedroom. How
do you say values the bathroom.
How do you say his name's Muse? Emmy Muse.
Muse told the police brain is lay in the
bath so the blood could flow away and
is slowly began to lose consciousness.
Muse passed the time reading a star trek
novel when the Berliner finally passed
out, muse cut his throat. Now
this is zoomed over a number.
He was consumed over a number of months,
the 30 kilos of flesh he
had put in his freezer. Wow.
Hughes went on the Internet
in search of a new victim. Oh.
So he became like a tasted frustrated
that he could only find people looking for
cannibal.
Roleplays muse began boasting about
Brandis someone from the chat room and
formed the federal police who swooped
in arm and Muse House in December 10th
last surprising the Koi Cannibal, then
startling the unsuspecting neighbors.
Whew. Wow. No, that's that. A sociopath
psychopath. And you were saying earlier,
yeah cause are you a psychopath
or you're a sociopath that point,
I mean how do you not feel empathy even
for a guy who's telling you to kill you,
but you're just looking, you know,
to kill somebody cause you have a taste
for blood now it became a blood thing,
right? Yeah. I bet whatever he
did during the day was boring.
And I bet that as psychotic
as it is was exciting.
And then he became a serial killer
chasing that. That feeling? Yeah.
What is it Jamie? What's
the matter? He's got it.
I,
I found a website that had
seven or something interesting
facts about this guy.
This is the first one
he sauteed and ate the peanuts
with his victim. Yeah, that was,
that was the story, right? Yeah.
Yeah. They, they cooked it together.
Sauteed it. Wow. Look at that image.
That's not really how it went down or
something. Yeah, that's enough though.
Does it say it? Like what?
How they sauteed the penis
too chewy for them.
Either of them to enjoy.
So they proceeded to fry it up with
some of his flesh and fat and a bit of
garlic.
Oh, that's hard. I mean that's not,
I guess it's like you're worried about
the end, right. And then you just say,
I'm going to take control. I'm going
to bring the end on and here it is.
You got where you were eating my
dick. This is over. This is not,
we're eating my tick. This is
not going to last. Eat My dick.
And then he goes into the tub to die
out from warm water with this dick hole
bleeding out. Just really insane
stuff. I mean, that's really it.
I mean to live through
that, by the way. Well,
you got to think that there's just such
a wide range of crazy people and there's
some crazy people like that that want to
be eaten and some crazy people want to
eat you. And if they find
each other though, that's,
that's the beauty of the
Internet. You can do that now.
You couldn't do that back in, you
know, the Donner era or even the, uh,
the 90s with Brazilian soccer
team at each other. Oh,
how long do you think that guy could,
could've kept it together if he just
ate that one dude before he could find
another guy that will let him eat
him. And if that was his thing,
what'd he just [inaudible] himself?
Right, exactly. What do you go?
What do you go Dexter and just go,
that's what I'm saying. Like bad people.
Yeah. Oh, that show was fucking,
I mean the, I mean just to, just
to go there and kill the guy.
Read his star trek novel. By the way.
Why the guy's bleeding out in
a tub after you ate his dick.
That's some psychopath shit.
Picking Dick out of your teeth and not
that I'm not sharing with you guys.
There are pictures of this online.
Oh No, no, don't do this. Yeah,
I don't need this. What I don't want
to see. Yeah, so dick is to chew.
You're going to say, I was like, don't
do this. Whatever you're going to do.
Don't do this. Said jurors have seek
therapy after they watched the video.
Oh yeah, I bet. Did see
PTSD. Of course they did.
And imagine being a juror and they
force you to watch that video. Yeah,
I don't want to see anybody yet.
I don't want to see you eat a dick and
you're the only ones watching it, right?
Because you've got to think that.
It's not like they're broadcasting on
television. Let me on fear of heck,
you guys did it like a,
like it was always like the big thing
of like eating somebody's penis,
right or something. Yeah.
No bull Titus one time they
had eat dicks, right? Yeah,
they had to eat like Bull Dick, dear
Dick, pig dick, something like that.
I forget what the decor,
but it was a bunch of different
kinds of dicks and they'll even,
they'll be like, it's
just something so strange.
I had a bit about it that like never
in my life that I think that I'd be
standing in front of a girl with a
plate full of animal dicks going,
you can do it. Hang in there, keep,
keep going, keep going. Use
Your just you control your mind.
Control your mind. Coaching them
through it. Nice. Through eating. Yeah.
Eating pig paint, pig,
penis. Ridiculous Dick.
But it's like you can't,
I look at things Jamie,
it's not legal to kill
yourself. It's illegal.
Suicide's illegal and it's
not legal to eat people.
And even if someone tells you to kill
them and eat them, you're not allowed to.
Even in Jeremy, like even like that,
cause that's assisted suicide, right?
Technically you can't what
it's cannibalism to like
we're, we don't allow that.
No sleep. Humanities doesn't
allow that. There's some tribes,
there's a few tribes is still
practice realism that particularly,
I guess I was reading,
I'm just not interested in like learning
what like what a human tastes like.
Well, it's probably not good, right?
Yeah. We eat a little trash cannibalism.
There's no laws against cannibals and
per se, but in most of not all states,
there have been enacted laws that
indirectly make it impossible to legally
obtain and consume the body matter.
That's when you put it that way. Yeah.
It doesn't sound too appetizer. If
you can get it, the body matter.
Wait a minute. Wasn't there a
show on CNN or one of their guys?
They, they wanted him
to eat charred flash.
Like he was, uh, examining
different religions.
Do you remember something
along these lines?
It was like some outrageous thing
like Gupta, Sandra or the, uh, no,
I don't think it was Sanjay Gupta was
someone else, but there was, they were,
he,
he visited all of these
different religions and
people that lived their lives.
Different, weird ways and
wonderful. I know the show you're
talking about. Yeah. I
don't remember that episode.
Can you write it wasn't Gupta. It
was a, a, another correspondent.
He eventually got fired for CNN
for saying something about Trump,
which is hilarious. Yeah.
Cause you're sparks outrage after
eating human brain in new show.
It takes like charcoal. See
the problem with that too,
by eating a human brain is that, I mean,
maybe these cults or these tribes or
whatever he's involved with does do that.
If the brain has prions,
prions are what gives you mad
cow disease. Oh really? Yeah.
Yeah. You can. Yeah. You can get sick
from that and die. Yucks Feld crap.
What does that name
event? Jake. Chuck Jakub.
Jakub crux fell disease. And it's, um,
it's basically mad cow disease
and you get it from prions.
Get it from brain tissue. So it takes,
they survive like thousands of degrees.
Yeah. Crux, Feld, Yacob
disease. That's it. Okay.
So the most rare degenerative fatal brain
disorder and affects about one person.
So some people get it without
cannibalism. Um, but it also does happen.
See One person every million worldwide.
The United States about
350 cases per year. Crazy.
So it must be like really charred
though. It doesn't matter. I don't think.
Really. Yeah, I don't think it does.
And he's still, he's still alive. Yeah.
Well he might not have had the
prions of someone who has a disease,
but if that person did,
that's why it it like it has to be the
temperature that it has to be cooked at.
It's supposed to be insane.
I think prions can survive like more
than a thousand degrees for a long period
of time. Okay. That's one of the
fears of like mad cow disease.
Like you really are not going to be
able to cook it well enough to keep that
shit from getting in your bloodstream.
Ah, yeah. Fuck. See Google.
How long Jamie, your Google off the all
off changed today. You got extra groove,
a lot of flesh talk today. Yeah.
How well what temperature do
pry on surviving cause uh,
I think it's more than a thousand
degrees and they can still survive,
which I remember reading that going,
Oh this is terrible. Mad cow disease.
Zombies. Zombies. Yeah,
exactly. It depends. I mean,
I mean you have your food so you're
not worried about that. Yeah,
but you should be worried because there's
a thing called chronic wasting disease
and chronic wasting disease is essentially
a form of like mad cow disease,
like very similar type of degenerative
disease that affects deer,
that it's affecting an increasing number
of from they're spreading across the
country now. It hasn't made the
jump to humans yet, but it could.
I don't want to worry here, but
you can't Deere, no more man.
Ions cannot be destroyed by
boiling alcohol acid standard
autoclaving methods or
radio or radiation.
That's what I'm saying.
They're like roaches. I think
they'll survive everything. Well,
you know what they are.
They're God's poison.
When God's like e nef
like no fire, no flames,
no ice, no water. You ain't fixing
this. This is coming in hot. Yeah.
And this is the, you can't
go yawns are forever.
Proteins are in the hard to kill hall
of fame and maybe more common than we
realize. See, this is what I'm
talking about. So these things,
this is what affects people
when they get mad cow disease.
And this is also what it affects.
Cannibals crux failed Yakup or Jakub
Cooksville the first way crux failed.
Yucca D. Okay. Crux failed Jakub
disease, but it affects cannibals.
They found out the cannibals
in New Zealand, New Guinea,
cannibals in New Guinea, um,
exhibited the same sort of, um,
symptoms as people with a
cross filled Jakub disease. Uh,
Google that jamming it
all. Fucking AP cannibals,
cannibals that get crux
felled Jakub disease,
those poor cannibals while they're
heating brain matter. That's what it is.
It just eat. Yeah, just eat the
flesh. Fries the flesh. Eat the booty.
The bone. Here you go.
Only only pork butts.
They evolved their resistance to it
because they were getting it so much.
Oh my God. That's crazy.
Wow. Good for them.
Cannibalism in one Papau New Guinea
tribe led to the spread of a fatal brain
disease called Kourou that caused a
devastating epidemic in the group.
But now some members of the tribe carry
a gene that appears to protect against
Kourou as well as others, so called
pry on diseases such as mad cow.
So they have it all. They evolve
that generational. Wow. Like a super,
like a superbug fucking
life finds a way, man,
to equalize that way and wonder how long
it's gonna take before we're physically
addicted to phones to the point
where you needed to stay alive.
I mean like you need use
warm clothes, right? In a,
in a cold environment,
you need a warm house.
How long before you need a
phone? Like, here's the thing,
the phones gonna help you. It's gonna
make everything better, but you need it.
So yeah, it's almost like a, like a heart
monitor. Like, I'm going to need this.
You have to have it. Wow. Ah,
it's gonna take generations and I can
access point to the Internet instead of a
phone, a way to access that.
Don't just call it a phone,
call it an electronics soul. I mean
will the phone is the only what?
The access to the Matrix, which is the
internet and that thing's not real,
you know, unless you live
inside of it, it's not real yet.
That's sounds drawing you in though.
How often you use your phone every day,
obviously. Yeah, obviously, but
it just gives, yeah. Honestly,
I'm using on it. I'm
not saying I'm above it,
I'm just saying and I'm not even sure why.
Although sometimes I'm searching
Google news just to see if something's
interesting. Yeah. I'll look at
the same news. What do you got?
Nothing in politics. Okay. About
entertainment. Nothing. Nothing, nothing.
How about outside gave me some
science. Come man, what do you got
rid of me? What do you got for me?
Just constantly, instead of
thinking about what I'm doing,
constantly searched for some
new data. It's weird, right?
It's, I mean it's happening. I like,
I mean, we can get rid of it. No,
we're talking about these are
the, like this generation of kids,
like this is the two girls, one cup
generation. You know what I mean?
Like they get to see it at like five
years old on their phone. Right. That's,
that's going to change.
So I think when you're saying
that's going to take generations,
I mean it could be what a few generations
removed moved from like where they,
you just, you don't know any
better if you don't have a phone.
Wow.
So we'd be at the faces
of death generation.
Cause like our parents probably never
saw that shit. But we definitely did.
They saw it in the war son. They saw,
they saw it in person, we saw it on TV.
You were there man. The first
bitch ass generation. I mean look,
I mean my generation were definitely the
chasses well when you go back to like
World War II, everybody was
signing up. Right, right.
Those people just signed up for the war.
But then he got around to
Vietnam. I was like, what? Yeah.
Well while we were there,
the fuck are we doing?
They manipulated that war though. So
that was different where we're to you,
like you, you know, Pearl
Harbor happened, you know,
there's no Pearl Harbor that happened
for Vietnam. Even nine 11 like, you know,
like the guys were signed
up to go, you know,
and quote unquote fight
those terrorists. You know,
this faction of dudes like how
many guys came back from war world,
World War II with
horrific memories. Right.
I remember saving private Ryan. Yeah.
That was one of the best
depictions of a historical event.
And to put it into like real perspective,
what it probably was like when those guys
were getting gunned down on the beach.
Yeah. You thought you yeah. You didn't
know who's going to be you or not. Yeah.
But it's also whoa, this is real as fuck.
And then imagine leaving that and coming
back and like you said to be normal.
Yeah. Cause most movies
that we saw about war,
like go back to like John
Wayne movies about war,
they would never gory is like bang,
they fall down, you know, ah, hold
his stomach. He didn't see anything.
And then later, even in
movies like apocalypse now,
I mean it was still wild and still
gave you this feeling of war,
but there was never anywhere near the
Gore of that scene and saving private
Ryan.
Then you see people with their legs
blown off and their guts hanging out and
you're like, Whoa, Lee, shit,
that's war. That's what a war.
We never saw that.
You never see that unless you're there
in the war or unless you're watching a
movie like that, cause the
movies that whitewash it,
they give it this feeling
of like, ah, yeah,
Bang,
Bang what they're exposed to as far as
their entertainment in the 1940s and then
boom, you're there and you're seeing
real war. I mean, they'll fucking, dude,
they'll scare you straight. Like why
would you want to go fight in that?
They were scared of the
Germans taking the world.
They see the world from the
Nazis. That's one of those rare,
it's a great way to put it,
save the world from the Nazis,
rare wars where it's not
that it's not that sloppy.
It's pretty clear. You got to realize,
guys are, yeah, they're evil, right?
Right, right. Fire. You have a legitimate
evil empire that's killing people.
They killed 6 million Jews
or whatever the number is.
What is the number? So they always did,
I said 5,000,001 time and somebody
correct. They always correct.
It's always 6 million,
whatever the number is.
Some insane number of millions of people
were killed by this one group of humans
genocide. And there was something that
history and pictures are one of the,
one of the Twitter accounts that I
retweeted a few days ago that had, um,
they showed all these ss officers
laughing and with like kids in their labs.
And the caption was
something to the effect of,
don't ever think that the people that
you think of as monsters are not human.
Like humans are capable regulations
and capable of horrific,
monstrous behavior if
they all agree to it.
And so it showed these ss officers and
they just looked so normal and laughing
and ha. Meanwhile,
there's these Jewish skeleton people and
living in a cage just a few yards over.
Well that with a, isn't it what a
cabaret is about kind of, right.
I was watching the movies on CNN. Yeah.
They're kind of saying like cabaret
is like, it's, it's showing how like,
like all these funny like nice people
and they just pick their Nazis.
So I didn't see that movie and it was
in that movie. I forget who said it,
but I know it's like a
musical [inaudible] wow. Yeah.
I never saw it. It was really all
about, I didn't know that either.
I've watched that. I've learned about
through Tom Hanks is the movies on CNN.
Well you've obviously never seen the man
who killed Hitler and then bigfoot all
of it. It's my guy.
Do you understand why the
Nazis are so bad? Yeah, it's,
we haven't had, yeah, you're right.
We haven't had somebody as evil
as the Nazis. Right, right.
But they've tried to make guys
like that, you know, the Vietcong.
So don was saying bin Laden, but that
one was clear cut. Like everybody,
that was Jesus. Let's go get, Hilary
had to stop this, this mother fucker.
When you see him scream in front of the
crowd, like little Dutch. Fuck fuck.
Yeah. Why would you follow that?
They're all high on the fucking
methamphetamines, aren't they though? Um,
let's see. Yes. Okay. Even if
we don't know, eat that Nazis,
he was tripping the video of
him. He was definitely tripping.
He was rubbing his cane on his deck.
He was tweaking but a whole country
he's into that. They're just like, Eh,
this is our guy. We're going
to do whatever he says.
Yup. Yup. They didn't even know.
They didn't even know like what it meant
to have someone like him run a country
back then,
how drugs like Pervitin and cocaine
fueled the Nazi's rise and fall.
Wow. Despite Hitler's anti-drug rhetoric,
Nazi Germany used a little courage called
pervert tin to take Europe by stern
storm. And it turns out it
was pure methamphetamine.
It is perverts in
methamphetamine. Hydro chloride.
Who made that?
It looks like the fucking Germans did
cause it's [inaudible] know what I'm
saying? Like who? Like what company,
what companies making Pervitin
some Nazi company. Okay.
So they would just given out everybody
math could have messed up country.
That makes sense. That'll kill
6 million Jews. Yeah. Oh, okay.
It says still couldn't dick
ditch an access power meeting.
So Hitler's personal physician injected
the fewer with a drug called you could
doll think oxycodone combined
with cocaine to perk him up.
Some physician took a significant
risk in doing so. After all,
Hitler was prone to latching
on to addictive substances
and refusing to let go,
but in this case, the
injection seemed warranted.
Hitler was doubled over with
violent spastic constipation,
refusing to speak to anyone immediately
after the first injection and despite
his doctor's wishes,
a revived Hitler ordered another injection
hit with then left for the meeting
with a Gusto of a soldier half his
age. Okay, so it's like, yeah, he's,
he was messed up, man. He's taken
like super pills or whatever.
He was taking liquid cocaine
and meth and oxycodone.
Hitler reportedly spoke for several hours
without stopping at the meeting with
Mussolini. Hitler reportedly spoke
for several hours without stopping.
The Italian dictator who
sat massaging his own back,
dabbing his forehead with
a handkerchief and sighing,
had hoped to convince Hitler to
let Emily drop out of the war.
He never got the chance. And you hear
the word in edgewise. Oh my God. So cute.
Imagine being poor Mussolini.
You're over there talking to Hitler.
He's math out of his fucking mind
and you're trying to tell him,
look Italian, the, we don't want to go
to war. We went to back out of this.
We like to just kick it back,
you know, I mean a good luck.
We, you know, we hope for the best
and Hitler comes over all messed up.
Have you heard rose wakers?
Yes. Okay. Here it says,
Jamie is trying to show us this.
This is what, he won't let it go.
This is what one episode of mid
Hitler's all his daily drug use,
which included barbiturates,
old-school bull, semen,
bull, semen, bull, semen, testosterone,
opiates and stimulants such
as perfect 10 a courage pill.
So he was taking math. Isn't bull seem
like Torian or whatever pulls him in?
The story is lit like the sounds like
it would be like red bull is like,
it's supposed to be like something.
It's supposed to be like a small
bulges bullshit. Take that red bull.
That's again some serious don't.
I've heard Torres, am I right?
Is he right? Torian is
bull semen. Oh my God.
[inaudible] ingredient and Rainbow
Monster, rock star and other energy.
It's an organic,
not an amino acid for named
for the Latin tourists,
which means ox or bull because originally
Torian was extracted from bull sea
bull semen. So originally
taurine was extracted that way,
but it is an ingredient in bull semen.
So the Taurine and red bull probably
doesn't come from bull semen,
but taurine is in bull semen.
So Hitler was getting his
touring right from the tap,
from the source, sucked the bowls.
Dick defeat best way is to
suck a pond. It sucked out.
Did you get it from the tap and it is
fresh and it's 700 pounds more potent.
The fewer is just gets down there. They,
they hold the bull back with
straps and buckles. It's kicking
and the Hitler gets this sloppy Nazi
mouth right over that fat oh hog.
And that is apparently the origin of
that upper lip mustache with muscles to
catch all the succulent drops when
he's choking on Jay's [inaudible]
flavor savor.
And that giant bold Dick is pummeling
the back of his throat and fills it up
that when he comes out of his nose,
cause a lot of the gyms
comes out of his nose.
That's just enough
mustache to catch the ges.
So that's why he had that mustache.
A lot of people don't know,
I must say I believe that many tables
followed that kind of guy. I mean like,
and everybody's just on
average is cracked out.
It's a perfect is catching
mustache. If you think about it,
it's coming out of your nose, which it
does do, right? Like milk does, right?
You, yeah, you cough when you drink
it out and it comes out of your nose,
you'll see him. He's coming out of your
nose and humans coming out, you know?
Yeah man, he's catching
it. Savoring it. No,
you're saying, I mean, I'm
just saying how many people,
how many people were in Germany at that
time? How many people were in millions?
Were were SS soldiers. I wonder,
that's a good question, right?
How many people actually joined? Yeah.
Well, I think you had to be a part of it,
right? Otherwise or youth as
well. Yeah. It was a whole, yeah.
The whole society was that. It was
all, yeah, it became Nazi Germany,
national socialist. What
is it? What is the actual,
what does Nazi actually stand for? I mean,
didn't shut up for seven hours, dude. Oh,
national socialism.
I guess that's a national socialist
German Workers Party as what it was.
So they were socialists.
Now Imagine Paul Mussolini,
then he killed more people. Uh,
I don't know how many he killed.
How many of Mussolini? Stalin didn't he
kill the most? He killed the most. Yeah,
he's, yeah, he's like a, he's,
he's, he's Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
Have a mass murder. She's got
the points record too, man.
How do you, when you're a person like
that, and you didn't used to be a Stalin,
right?
You were just a person and then all of
a sudden you're in a position of power
and then all of a sudden
you're responsible for the
death of untold millions of
people, almost tunes.
So some was the most,
a long shot look at Mao,
Hitler and then stolen 17 yeah,
the Mussolini on the list. Okay. But Mao,
the mile was like 400 million, right?
So 78 but he, I don't know. Okay,
go Google.
Mao might've been responsible for 400
million because there was an article I was
reading yesterday, 400 million people.
That's that they revise the amount
of people that they think are,
were dead directly because of
mile. Okay. Oh, so like indirectly,
the earlier you were saying
directly killed 400 people,
some insane number of people
were killed during miles rain.
What are they saying?
That's crazy. Wait, wait.
There's a place called Mao's
kitchen. 5 million maybe.
Maybe I added a zero to it. Leap forward.
Maybe I added a zero most likely.
So 45 million and the
other ones had 70 so it's,
so it's between 45 and whatever
the other number is. But that,
so he's number one with a bullet. Wow.
He's the guy responsible for the most
death. During his time, again though,
there was a, there was
a kitchen, there was a,
a restaurant here in Los Angeles
called mouse kitchen. Jesus,
that's disrespectful as fuck. Tyson
has mal on his arm. Oh, does it? Well,
I mean, you know, he's
supposed to kill people,
but I was in Williams in jail I think.
Probably read some philosophy from Mao.
I mean, yeah, those guys. I mean those
guys great. They read good books.
Well my comp is a, it's pretty
good. Is it, did you read it?
I wrote it in English. Are you allowed
to read it now? Like when you read it,
you're probably allowed
to read it. Like if you,
I don't think you can buy it today. Yeah.
But he tried to buy mine on your kindle.
If you're like sales stuff, it's like,
it's, it's just like talking
about the sale. I mean,
it's obviously talking about,
you know, killing Jews,
but talking about like
the sale of, it's just,
it's talking about how they can overcome
and it's like his struggle is basically
just, it's a, it is a
propaganda book, but it's like,
it's from a sales perspective, you're
just like, I see where he's coming from.
Not Saying that I'm condoning it,
but I'm saying you're like, okay,
there's so much passion in it. You
know what I mean? It's like a minute.
It's like a memoir.
So he's selling to the people that they
can overcome the economic situation that
Germany's in and they can rise above this.
And if you tried to buy that today to
read it, people would assume I was young.
I read about the way I would
think, oh, you combine my income.
They buy it on Amazon, but come on son,
you know, you're on a list. Ah, you,
I am now. Right. I read in the
library, they like the library.
If you buy it today, you know this.
Yeah, for sure. Like better flag.
You're gonna list now. Oh yeah, for sure.
If you buy a Duke's, it had DVD set,
you're on the list. You're on the list.
We doing just faster if it's one on the
cover of the one with the general Lee
leaping over the fucking canyon with
the confederate fag flag clearly
booked at, I think it was maybe
the one you talk about a lot,
but I remember in the 90 [inaudible] late
nineties you people were saying if you
went into the bookstore to buy this book,
you're on a list and if you had to go
buy with cash and like wear a Hoodie and
cover your face. Yeah, I remember that.
It was always those stupid rumors. Yeah.
What was the book? I think it was the,
the cross book that you've talked about,
the Sacred Cross or oh, the sacred
mushroom in the cross. Yeah,
that's the one I would heard of. It
could have that. My rumor might
get passed around a lot. Yeah,
nine years or something. Do you
remember a course in miracles?
Of course in miracles is a
book that was going around,
I want to say in the
early, early nineties,
there was a bunch of people that were
telling you to read some book by this
couple and they were channeling an
angel. They wrote this book. And uh,
yeah,
it's one of those books where I like w
I don't know if it was any good because
everybody that recommended
it was so annoying
or like you pray love or was that the
other one? The A, the secret? Well,
it was extremely spiritual
air quotes and uh,
it was all about how to live
and it might've been, it
might be an amazing book,
but I remember everybody that wanted
to recommend that I always had like a,
that might,
I was a young man at the time and I was
very dismissive about a lot of things.
I wouldn't be dismissive
of today, but the,
I remember it was like one of those books
where annoying people loved it. Yeah.
You've got to read this book,
right? That kind of, yeah.
It's like this book
transformed me. It's a gift.
I'm giving you this book because I
want you to read it and it's going to
transform you to wow. This made me
getting my love to you. Maybe a,
I'm reading a book about someone who
said they were channeling and angel and
that's nonsense, right about that.
How about I have to think about
the fact it's a nonsense person.
Foundation for inner peace.
Look good. Look the light. Oh,
it looks like the dianetics
[inaudible] yeah. Oh, exactly. Yeah.
It's very cultish. What is the, um,
what's the origin of it? Is it, does it,
am I correct?
Did it come from someone who like
channeled an angel or some shit like that?
Isn't that the idea? Well,
let's Google. What is the origin
continue curriculum aiming at assisting
readers and achieving spiritual
transformation.
Am I conflating this with some other
book we were talking about in colors?
Someone was almost the same thing,
but where someone said that
like someone wrote it for them,
that it was like written as they
were channeling. Oh really? Like, oh,
Oprah to talk about it in 1982 did
they say that or am I making this up?
I'm trying to see what it says too quick.
So listen to Oprah's book clubs on Johnny
Carson to split. Got around 90, right.
I don't think you gonna follow it
to find it from there. Just Google.
What is the origin story for a course
of miracles, of course in miracles.
But it was one of those
books where you'd like,
if you were dating a yoga teacher or a
house, she'd have it on the coffee table,
on your way to the Vegan restaurant.
Let's go. You know, I mean,
cause you think like, if the Nazis do win,
that does become like the coffee
book and comp. Yeah. If the Nazis,
once super inspirational and
inner voice, she identified as Jesus, uh,
began interacting with her
and acted as a stimulus,
triggering a series of inner experiences
that were understood or to her as that.
And that's what she does.
So at the same guy who said, who wrote
the Mormon Bible said the same thing,
man. Yeah. Yeah. So that's
what it is. So I'm correct.
So it's like a Bible. Wow.
It's like one of those things
like maybe that happened.
Maybe that happened.
I mean sold some books obviously that
maybe you're crazy maybe or maybe you're
out of your fucking mind and you want
people to think that you're special.
So you wrote these rules on how
people should live and they,
they're pretty good. They're resonate.
Well that makes sense because you're not
selling the original Bible to a hundred
percent crazy.
This is good structure where we assume
that if someone tells a crazy story like
that, they're a hundred percent crazy.
Right? I didn't have any good ideas.
Like you could be a fucking crazy
person with a couple of good ideas.
Like Mike is fucking crazy.
But I'm telling you, they
said JK Rowling was crazy.
Oh, she's got to be crazy. So this,
she's got Harry Potter Shit right there.
That little boys. Yeah. Tell you right
in the mouth. Yeah. A little boys magic.
Actually. Cute little girl.
If [inaudible] let everyone
be happy and happy and happy.
Like you can be a woman and do
that, right? You can be a dude.
And do that because then you're like,
yeah dude, writing about a little boys.
Not Good. That's definitely a, that's
a flag to be able to get away with it.
Right?
Like Dr Seuss Twain wrote
about like huckleberry Finn
and those boys snort that.
I was like, oh well this all this
meth talk mushroom elixir. Oh,
you want something it's going to do to
me like lion's mane juice me up. No, no.
Should good for the brain. No perfect.
It doesn't taste bad either. Thank you.
Why is that actual lion's mane?
Yeah, lion's Mane. Mushroom,
not lion's like a lion.
Lion. It's a mushroom.
Just drink it all the time and I feel
like it'd be rude if I don't want you. So
you're the man.
Jeez.
I was going to correct something
you asked me earlier. Uh,
UFC 21 was when that changed,
there was a significant rule change and
they joined with the Council of Mixed
Martial Arts Commission.
You'll see 20 war prelim bouts it at
two rounds that were only five minutes.
Then three, five minute rounds
and championship bounds.
Change it five minutes.
They also, that's when they
added a 10 point must system.
So prelim rounds were two rounds.
Championship rounds were
three championships were
five [inaudible] everything
else was three. Oh, before
that. Cause there were,
so before that it was too though you said.
But this was also pre
Dana and pre cheetahs.
So they were still mixed like the
Gracie stuff, they were doing it.
So they just had five minute rounds
until the thing was over unlimited five
minute rounds. That's right. I remember
that Shit. That was a, that was madness.
But it wasn't as bad in terms
of badness as the Japanese ones.
The Japanese ones were fucking
crazy. They did so many nutty things.
They had so like
crazy freak shows and
they still do. Right.
They had this lady named Gabby Garcia.
She's like six foot two, 240 pounds.
Amazon they have are
fighting like housewives.
She beats loves his ladies and
it's all consensual. Right?
Like when they're signing up they like
freak shows. You're right. They, I mean,
yeah, look at their game shows. Yeah,
exactly. All that is going on with that.
It's just cause I think there's such a
repress country, aren't they? I think so.
Yeah. I think this is like,
I don't think they have like vending
machines where like guys have like there's
Gabby, look at that. I wrote a mud.
She's spending of housewives. Look it up.
Look at the guns. Yeah.
We'll pull up a video of her given SWAPO
that's Rhonda Rousey. That's not real.
This is real Abby. That's fine. It's real.
So look at the size of that
woman that she has to fight.
I mean like what is up with the
definition though, Gabby? Um,
Mexican supplements. Hundred
percent. Nice. I don't use gap.
Keep it 100
sounds bigger than your trader.
[inaudible] silver. Yeah, that's nuts.
That's crazy. Yeah. She's a big lady.
But uh, so anyway, Japan loves him.
That was when she was real thin.
At one point in time she'd gotten like
real ripped and small and then got right
back up to gigantic.
I again to win in these fucking
Japanese events. She in a UFC?
No, she fights for, I think I'm
going to, which one might be rising
pop out randomly. It doesn't say which
one, but um, yeah, Washington like, uh,
so I mean, well she's bigger than like
every female and UFC. Yeah. She's giant.
She's got no, she ended a division.
Yeah, she's giant. She's a six too. Jeez.
I mean, she's in the
240 pound weight class. Somewhere
like that. A heavyweight.
It'd be heavyweights and male. Right.
And you can't, yeah, Gabby. Oh,
I'm going to be 62 no heavyweight female
weight class was her a couple of weeks
ago. It's not that big anymore. Oh,
she's shrinking down. [inaudible] hey,
good for her. What up? Still?
Probably 200 pounds. Damn. Okay.
So she's jacked and Tan again. She
looks great. Thin. Yeah, look good.
She's strong as fuck. And she's a
world champion Jujitsu player too,
so she grabs a hold. These
girls just pummels them,
but they had Bob Sapp back in the day.
Like I said, he was like 375 pounds.
It was fighting. Guys were in like the
two hundreds he smashed so many people.
There was so many guys like that,
that fought in Japan where
they had these freak shows.
I mean crazy as if I saw one the other
day, like the thing where like a uh,
like a woman than her nipples were just
like almost like a like cones and then
like the game shows like these guys are
just like put their fingers in the is
just wild. I mean there's just
so many wild things in Japan.
Like you can see things. It is gnarly Bro.
Well they are the birth of a lot
of those crazy game shows, right?
I mean a lot of the game
shows like even fear factor.
Like would that have even happened if
it wasn't for the crazy Japanese shows?
What's in the water with it
to make them think like the,
and we were saying they were
oppressed but it's also,
I mean why they sober pressed?
Have you ever seen Bazooka man?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
man was a Japanese game show where a
guy with a bazooka would show up at
people's houses. Okay. I
think a real live bazooka,
like with like missile in bed, be in bed,
sleeping and bazooka man would shoot
the bazooka at your wall above your head
while you were asleep. This is a real
film. It what? They would film it.
This thing will explode above your head.
Shoots a rocket launcher
through your fucking wall. Boom.
And these guys like they
wake up fucking screaming.
There's a hole in the wall above the
head and the audience in Japan's like ha
ha. Do you have, you can find
it. You can find the videos.
Barbara, Jamie and find it. What is that?
That's a real [inaudible] had a
different name maybe rocking man.
[inaudible] man. Okay. So I'm
pretty sure it was bazooka man.
And it's a real rocket, whatever it is.
It's firing out of a cannon that's on
his shoulders and it's hitting the wall
and explodes. Right.
Google Japanese game show
where they blow up wall behind.
I mean I have like a heart
attack and like when you wake up,
like they're dead asleep. Yeah, easily
could. And that's what I'm saying. Until,
I mean you must like sound like
a death warrant for you. Uh,
for sure he could definitely get a heart
attack though Jesus. And like you said,
it's like dead asleep and they all sign
up for this is all consensual basically.
Okay. Understand. I don't
think they sign up for it.
I think they're just allowed
to do stuff like that.
And then they give you money.
Okay. If you survive. Right.
Well I don't think they have the same
concept of lawsuits that we do over here.
Okay.
You got it. Oh No, no. I'm on my way
to finding it though. I found one a,
this is called the bum show where girls
would put their bum in a hole and a guy
would kiss it or eat their ass basically.
Right on t v okay. Yeah.
Can't comment on that one. They
have different ways of living.
They really do have a different style.
Can hate it. Can Be Hating on him.
Jesus. Is it China or
Japan where they have a,
like they have like these crazy
work hours, right? Like, like Steve,
like factory workers were like, you
know, just like the whole kind of me.
It's just like work all the time.
And they have vending machines where
you can just like pocket posts these
basically. Oof. Yeah. They'd like
the guys were just like there. Yeah.
They'll just use those things. They'll
toss them. Oh, then just go back to work.
Oh yeah. Wow. I want to say that's,
that's Japan. That could be,
well they both have, they're
both known for their work hours,
you know, so like sex just isn't a part
of the routine that was watching some,
um,
document around or reading something
rather on Huawei while always this Chinese
phone company and the guy had a bed
underneath his desk as crazy as image.
He's in his cubicle and his stuff is above
him and he's got a bed laid out under
his cubicle and he's asleep
with his, like glasses at work.
Exhausted isn't really an 18 hour day
probably making cell phones so we could
take selfies. I like the way China has
like the biggest, uh, economy though.
The biggest. Yeah. Don't they are the
number one, Huh? Yeah. The Chinese,
I've been pretty right on this whole
episode, Joe. Very right. Shocking.
Damn [inaudible]. So the
largest economy, China
and what's number two?
It's American number two because
that's somebody he used to tell Trump.
He keeps saying number one. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm sorry to hurt anybody that didn't
know that. But China's number one.
Well I guess it depends on what you're
using to gauge economy as a general.
It's like not as just a thing.
Oh, it's not subjective. I'm
sorry. It's not the objective
p or you know, give me people,
cause it says our GDP is 19.3 9 trillion
and China's is 12 which is their
nominal, but over more people,
I guess it's 23 trillion.
So that's technically
higher. That's where it goes.
I don't know what you want to,
okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. What
you're basing your economy on, so GDP,
we're killing it. But as
far as large as the economy,
it's the Chinese [inaudible]
got way more people. Okay.
So that's probably why though,
as large as kind of maybe because they
more paypal a billion humans, right?
Yeah. Does India bigger than the
biggest country still? China?
That's another good question. Yeah, I
think it's close. That's our hot race.
China and India.
Yeah. Is there stuff from earlier
this year saying in China,
in India are gaining on the u s as the
world's top economy or they're poised to
take over next year? So I don't think it
really just depends on what you want to
imagine. If Trump is onto
something with all these sanctions.
Imagine you're talking about the
a that health insurance thing.
Earlier I learned a weird thing. I,
a British comic had told me when I was
over in London last year doing the,
the roast battle over there
and uh, he was like, you know,
like you guys don't have
free healthcare. He's like,
but your healthcare is better. He's
like, usually when I get like a,
he had like a bronchial
thing and he's like, uh,
normally takes like two weeks for
that to cure over here. He's like,
I went to America, took like 48
hours. That's what we're paying for.
Just the better drugs. That makes
sense. Not just better drugs,
but like probably more motivated
doctors, but he was getting paid.
But are they more motivated to keep
people in and out of their office and
shuffle them quick and stuffed them
up with pills versus we're an England,
they're not motivated
by like a quota. Right.
Maybe they're just just trying to help.
Maybe it's different because they get
paid a certain amount and healthcare is
free and they're not motivated
to earn additional profit by,
you know,
suggesting surgeries or making
someone get on medication.
I don't know. But it's all, I mean
if you're talking about it, listen,
I'm a doctor, I'm making money over
here. Right. When you want to keep a guy,
you know, sick as possible, he can
make more money out of them. Yeah,
but that's like say some dark
conspiracy type thing. Definitely.
How many people are really
thinking like that? Right.
But I'm saying like two weeks
to encrypt it. Like 48 hours.
It's just a shittier system.
That's what I'm saying.
May Be the argument can be made that
profit based systems are efficient because
people are more aggressive
cause they want them,
they want to make money because they get
things handled quicker and they believe
in it more. It's almost like I'm
getting what I paid for. Maybe. Yeah.
I don't know. I,
I think it would be nice if people
didn't go out without health care though.
The problem is like the idea
that health is not a human right.
If that's not a human right,
what else do they have?
Like kids hurt and you just going
to let them die because they don't,
they don't contribute
enough change. You know,
they didn't put enough money in the,
in the box and basically bankrupt
now because I got a great knee.
It seems crazy that we would somehow or
another keep people from medical care.
I cannot have enough money.
Like that should be like the
number one thing that they had.
Care Food and medical care, food, shelter,
medical care, those things, you know,
not necessarily in that order. The
fact that medical, you're on your own.
Like what?
How come we can't pay for that when we
couldn't pay for the this and paid for
that and we can fund that and fund
this and we're going to go to the moon
tomorrow. But you gave, yeah,
but you can have healthcare.
But then again, it's like people
are so resistant to socialism,
like they don't want anybody
taking over and Nazis weren't. No,
they fucked up though. Look where that
ended. That's true. Terrible. Yeah.
They're all, they're all meth.
That's true. They're messed up.
Maybe non messed up socially.
But the problem is people are almost
all messed up here now with the fucking
Adderall thing. Yeah. Oh
yeah. Or the other on downers.
Like Xanax dude. Yeah, one of the other,
but Adderall might as well be math get,
it's some, it's cocaine. It's, it's
amphetamine. It's an amphetamine.
It's fucking straight up
amphetamine, you know?
And some people that helps some people
that works for them, but other people,
they just chew it all day long
and talk crazy. Talk Crazy.
Told me get the mouth crazy.
I mean, no one's against them.
Coke is the most annoying
drug. I mean it's the worst.
Yeah.
Just as on the noise level because
people are just talking about nothing the
whole time. You know? We just want to
talk to you talk right in your face.
Super pumped up like Hitler.
He imagined they injected him.
Two doses of oxycodone and cocaine to any,
it hits me again. The doctors I could
kinda like can't teach you again.
They hit him again. He goes directly
to Mussolini's house like, Oh God,
like he's so annoying. Coke fueled five
hour rent and rain. Poor Mussolini.
I just want to make a pizza.
Hang out. I want to go to Capri.
And when they go fishing with my
grandson, there's just like no,
the Cho and just losing his mom like God.
Imagine that this whole
thing was fueled by meth.
Like that was responsible
for the whole fucking chaos.
All that's fueled because if you
stop and think about history,
there's obviously been some
horrific, you know, campaigns. Well,
whether it's Alexander
the Great Gangas Kahn,
what are they on? You know what I
mean? What are they going to say?
That's how I was going to say,
like if these guys in the
Nazi party were all on Meth,
which makes total sense.
They were so psychotic. Dude,
what would the fucking Mongols on?
Will they just drunk? Yeah. Was it?
Yeah. Cause there was like, were
they, was that the opium den time?
That wasn't dens. I know. Yeah, they
definitely must had opiod Dems, right?
Yeah. They must've had
that. Is that their era?
I mean the gang is coming. I
hope Ian's been around forever.
Everybody had opium, but
it's what did, but that also,
that mellows you out though, right?
That shouldn't make you a killer. Wow.
The Vikings were in the mushrooms,
which is weird. Really? Yeah.
Like psychedelic mushrooms. Psilocybin.
They would take psilocybin,
they would fucking go on crusades and
start smashing heads. Oh, that's probably,
well, they're all so, you know, they're
grown to be like that, so I think, yeah.
You know, so little side was going to
take you where you want to go. Yeah.
Because it's also their world.
Their world is like cutting and slashing,
attacking. It's like they're not,
the idea of that not being there. That's
not even an option. Exactly. Yeah.
I mean, you talk about Bell House. I
mean that's what they're thinking about.
They're just like, we're just killing
people, but it's like, it's heaven.
Like we get to, we get to kill everybody.
What a crazy reward from murder.
You go to heaven and you drink
with Odin, going to go to Valhalla.
Can people apartments or just
can't wait to see Odin. Ah,
ah. And then you take
that Arrow and the neck.
You get to go to Valhalla for
happy. You got to go to Valhalla.
There was watch that show vikings. Now
people will tell me it's great though.
It was a great,
really fucking good man up until like
season four or five Mrs Rogan had to stop.
No did shake anymore. That's a lot
of fucking pretty extreme violence.
It gets a little bit handle it. It
gets a little gnarly and there's not,
the combat sports guy is not enough. Uh,
good people like route for Vikings.
Everybody's kind of a
piece of shit. You're like,
why am I watching these pieces?
Shifts, rape and murder each other.
And brothers would turn on brothers.
Mean, it's dark. And those are like the,
those are like the true Caucasians,
right? Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
They're the message. Northern Warriors,
the ones who escaped from the southern
climates and figured out how to survive
in the coldest fucking places in
the world. Oh yeah. And there's a,
there's like a nature rule,
not a rule like a law in terms of like
the size of things that live where it's
cold. So like if you
have a deer in Mexico,
it might be a hundred pounds, but
if you have a deer in Saskatchewan,
it might be like 300 pounds because of
the weapon species or something about
real cold climate makes things grow
bigger and stronger cause it's an, oh,
that's like, it's reacting to
the environment, right? Yeah.
It's something about a body
temperature as well that they,
in order to maintain body
temperature that you need a lot of.
And so like polar bears are
the biggest of the bears.
They live in the coldest fucking place.
And those Caucasian vikings
are the biggest dude.
Nice land motherfuckers
Icelandic, just giant dudes. Yeah.
That mountain from game of Thrones,
right? Yes. Yes. That's what that is.
That's no early. That's gnarly.
And he wanted to play basketball.
He want to play basketball cause he
ain't even made yet. Get both. No. Okay.
No, I don't think he knows how to fight.
There was a video of him sparring with
Conor McGregor and carm Connor McGregor
is fucking him up. What? That guy?
Yeah, and Connor mean, Connor's not a,
he's not weighing in.
So he's probably weighing about one
70 and game of Thrones guys, easy.
Three three is easy.
I would imagine he's in the three 2140
range and he's like a bodybuilder too,
so he's like chasing Connor and
Connor's cracking them in the stomach.
It's kind of a crazy video to watch. I
will see you see exactly the, pull it up.
Boom. Totally cut it. Five, nine
uh, this guy is what? Six seven?
He's taller than five. Nine. I
think Connor might be five now.
It might be five 10. I'm five.
Eight. He's a well disrespected.
She call her McGregor.
Oh, he's a beast. Yeah.
You get the hardest eight foot person.
He doesn't give a fuck. Yeah. I mean,
the guy fought Floyd Mayweather with
zero professional boxing fights.
Just stop and think about that. No,
he's here. Right? He took a zero.
So He's a legit, here's,
Connor was probably about a buck 70
look at the size difference here.
And they're like sparring
and Connor's moving around.
He's punched him in the stomach and the
guys trying to tag on tag and tried to
grab him. But Connor let him grab,
but he's not doing anything. He's,
he's controlling the guys trying to do,
so they're really spoiling
the guys trying to grab him,
but he doesn't know what he's doing.
And then he's like high five
and Kyle's like, no, no, no,
we're gonna keep going. We're
gonna keep going. So now he starts,
he starts kicking him, starts
kicking him in the [inaudible].
See he just punched him in the stomach
and the big guy, I know what to do.
He's trying to grab him, but it
Kinda is like, come on lad. I can,
I keep going monster. Yeah.
So probably Connor knows that this
big motherfucker can't keep this up.
He can't keep it out. He's not,
he's not able to keep up this pace.
So He's already hurting. Cause I
mean he's already tired me. Come on.
You going back and forth here?
No, no, no. First of all,
he's not even just got to a minute.
He's not used to sparring, right.
So everything he's doing is like these
big movements and he's not breathing
well. So he's all tense and
tight right now to went to,
could take a deep breath, see all this
is tension for him. He's very tense.
So now he's got a hold of the leg,
but he doesn't know what to do and kind
of habit kind of hand fights with them.
Connor has to do is keep
him moving as he always say,
punch counter in the stomach. There
we go. And it Kinda is like, oh, okay.
So Connor's going to keep going to that
and now he's throwing kicks at him and
the guy's going to kick them
yet I can't put that little bit.
It'll be too awkward and
Congo kind of trip him,
throw him to the ground or something
like that. He doesn't know how to kick.
But kind of just going to keep
punching him in the stomach,
but eventually just gets
really tired and he gives up.
But it's kind of crazy to watch, cause
Connor essentially made him fight. See,
look, he put a gun on his knees just
like that cop guy. That was, that was a,
that was a bit, yeah.
The victim with the cop.
He got on his knees and Connor didn't,
didn't allow him either. Consciously,
Nina, when the body look
at this bro, he's gangster.
He's kneeing him and punched him
in the body. Geez. I mean those,
and those are real kicks.
Those were real like neat too.
That guy is so much bigger than
him. He's a monster. So yeah,
he's not doing it. And the training,
well that's, I mean he could,
he wasn't there. I mean he
just doesn't know what to do.
But if he learned what to do of,
would never do that, that guy's a,
he's a walking weapon,
like liking gone. Who?
Franciscan and who was probably one of
the biggest heavyweights in the UFC.
Conor would never do that with
him. Yeah, he's a train. Yeah.
He's a trained fighter. Giant striker
who fuck them up. Put that guy.
That guy didn't know what, who's doing
no, the mountain though. Yeah, he's a,
uh, he was a basketball player.
He went to play basketball
and then he broke his, uh,
his ankle or leg or something
and, and never like heal properly.
And he just became a, a body builder and
then they put him in game of Thrones.
Well, he's a world strongest man. Yeah.
He wins those world's strongest man.
He's not just like a participant. Sorry.
Yeah, he is. Yeah. He's the champs.
He's crazy strong. It has guys like
magnets for Magnuson. Right? Like this,
like his mentor, Magnus said his
mentor. Yeah. Magnets for Magnuson.
What by what a great name.
Perfect name. Magnus for magnet.
I fucking love that kid. Strong man.
Competent competitor. Magna. Whom?
Audi magnets for
Magnuson. Yeah, there was,
I remember we watched those shows used
to be on like ABC Wide World of sports
and Chin would be on TV. You'd be
watching the strongest man competition.
They would throw throw barrels over the
fucking bars. I mean they're carrying,
yeah, like carrying trucks. 18 wheel
semis. Yeah, always ridiculous shit.
Remember like the guys like they would,
they had, they would lift and they like,
they had to have like a, a hemorrhage
and it just fucking go through the nose.
[inaudible] deadlifts.
Yeah. One of the guys,
Robert Oberst was on my podcast recently.
He's a, he's one of those strong,
strongest men. Competitors.
They're so big.
They don't even look like real people.
You're around them like, hi so big.
There's so big fucking gigantic
humans. The human buddy's incredible.
It is man. [inaudible] areas. Ah,
what did he ticking his nose
smelling salt. Isn't that nuts?
They do smelling salts before they left.
Some dudes drink whiskey or something.
Yeah, but why smelling salts? You
know, I wouldn't drink the whiskey.
I feel like that would
make me too relaxed.
I'd probably shoot myself or something.
Okay. The signs of this fucking human,
that's what he's four
25 to three [inaudible].
How much weight is this? It didn't say
this. A ton. Just said is the most proud.
Look at the ars are God,
Jesus Christ. Look at
the fucking bar bend.
Jesus. Good enough to spoken Chai, but
the smelling salts was so strange. Yeah,
right. Oh, [inaudible] please
do the tool in silence.
If you did that right before you went
on stage. [inaudible] salts. I might.
Maybe that's the moon, right?
Maybe we're missing out.
I think for your next year.
You got to do that shit.
Just fucking want to pound door
real quick. Can't live a Mussolini.
I just go up there and just rant
for five hours. Everybody's like,
shout him out. Did you see Rogan's seven
hour set. Oh my God. Oh, took smelling.
Oh, brilliant. His nose was bleeding.
Smell like took the best angles.
Now I don't know how to compare like
a steak bomb or something like that.
That's like real strong,
strong. I'm like, God,
it just get out. It pops your brain
like Ludwig. Then you have fucking
damn. Yeah. You become like Dane Cook
on the side. You'd be like so physical.
No one's dad physical. No one's
for smelling salts. Physical,
physical. We should make Jeremiah
walk-ins do it. Oh my goodness.
He would Watkins on smelling salts.
He would be the first guy to be have
like what kind of physical comedies you
have? I like smelling salts.
Physical, the most physical level.
That cocaine. Yeah, that isn't shit.
You're talking about smelling salt.
Well who's like, it'd be like Dang
Cook is one of the most physical,
like Jim Carrey was very
physical. The Williams. Yeah.
But Jim Carrey would like fall down and
fucking do pratfalls and [inaudible]
acrobat. Yeah. He couldn't move weird too.
He had like a real flexibility to the
way he moved and bring like ace Ventura
pet detective. I mean he that
was on display, right? Yeah.
I mean that was part of his whole
thing was how wacky he moved, you know,
nail with a thousand faces. Right.
With then you'd have smelling salts,
physical next level shit. Just
like those kids in the day.
They couldn't do the BMX flipped three
times and now they can. They can't. Yeah.
That's the same thing with
smelling solids. I gotta see this.
I gotta fucking try this.
Actually ammonia is it? Yeah.
Just it at a release is ammonia when you
break the thing or when I open the cap
or whatever. Okay. Oh, that's nothing.
That ain't shit. That's Windex.
Make it from deer antlers
and hooves. Oh Shit.
Called spirit of heart shorn. Folks.
This has been the most educational
experience ever of this podcast,
I would say, with both real and
false information. We don't know.
We get aside from which is we've,
we gave you nonsense and we gave
you truth and we hope you enjoy it.
Brian Moses tells people
where they can find you. Yeah.
You get by me at race
banning on Twitter, Fox,
Compton on Instagram,
or just see me at the rose bottle every
Tuesday night at the comedy store or
every Tuesday night.
At what time does it start at 11 o'clock
11:00 PM one of the rare scheduled
11:00 PM shows anywhere. How about that?
Regularly scheduled show at
11:00 PM pretty fucking rare.
It's dope, dude, that you came one
time. It was past your bedtime,
but you still did it. I took my, my
Atlanta. Yeah, that's it. Ladies
and gentlemen. Brian Moses. Goodbye.
[inaudible].